COMMITTEE ON CALIFORNIA, MEXICO
COLLABORATION AND DIALOG. IT'S
MY HONOR TO CHAIR THAT
COMMITTEE. WE MAY HAVE SOME
COLLEAGUES OF MINE IN THE SENATE
BREEZING IN AND OUT DURING THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING. I HOPE
YOU'LL BEAR WITH US. IT'S AN
INTERESTING TIME IN THE CAPITOL
RIGHT NOW WITH FOLKS IN AND OUT,
SO I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS
CONVERSATION AND HEARING FROM
SOME OF OUR ESTEEMED PANELISTS.
I THINK AS MANY OF YOU KNOW, WE
HAVE A UNIQUE, OVERLAPPING,
INTERDEPENDENT, SHARED HISTORY
BETWEEN THE STATE AND BETWEEN
MEXICO. AND IT'S INTERTWINED IN
CURRENT EVENTS, I THINK PREVENT
PRESENT US A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY
TO DEVELOP AN AGENDA THAT CAN
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION AND
BRING INTO FOCUS LONG OVERDUE
REPRESENTATION AND PARTICIPATION
ON GENDER. IN MEXICO, WE HAVE
THE HISTORIC ELECTION OF THE
FIRST WOMAN PRESIDENT, PRESIDENT
ELECT CLAUDIA SHEINBAUM. THE
RECENT ANNOUNCEMENT OF THE
NOMINATION OF VICE PRESIDENT
KAMALA HARRIS AS A STANDARD
BEARER FOR A MAJOR POLITICAL
PARTY IN THE UNITED STATES,
FORMER SENATOR AND ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ADDITION IN
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
DISTINGUISHED WOMEN LEADERS IN
THE RACE TO BE THE NEXT GOVERNOR
OF CALIFORNIA IN THE 2026
ELECTION. IN OUR HISTORIES,
COLLIDE AND COINCIDE IN WAYS
THAT CAN ALLOW FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AN AGENDA
CENTERED AROUND GENDER EQUITY
AND GENDER REPRESENTATION. BUT
BUILDING THIS AGENDA AND
PROVIDING THIS PERSPECTIVE AND
FOCUS DOES NOT HAPPEN OVERNIGHT.
WITHOUT APPROPRIATE DIALOG
UNDERSTANDING AND POLICY
MECHANISMS. MEXICO, FOR THE
FIRST TIME, IS REQUIRING
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION POLICIES FOR
FEDERAL, SENATORIAL POSITIONS,
REQUIRING THAT POLITICAL LEADERS
NOMINATE PEOPLE FROM
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES,
INCLUDING MIGRANTS, INDIGENOUS,
AFRO-AMERICAN, AND PEOPLE WHO
IDENTIFY AS LGBTQ AND THOSE THAT
LIVE WITH DISABILITIES. IN 2019,
CONSTITUTIONAL REFORMS REQUIRED
BALANCED REPRESENTATION OF WOMEN
AND MEN IN CANDIDACIES AND
POSITIONS IN THE EXECUTIVE,
LEGISLATIVE, AND JUDICIAL
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT. ALTHOUGH
CALIFORNIA AND MEXICO HAVE MADE
GREAT STRIDES IN THE FIGHT FOR
GENDER EQUALITY, EQUITY AND
REPRESENTATION, BUILDING AN
AGENDA CENTERED AROUND THIS THAT
CROSSES BORDERS AND BLENDED
CULTURES WILL REQUIRE A DEEPER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE UNIQUE
LEGAL AND POLITICAL ASPECTS OF
BOTH OUR GOVERNMENTS AND OUR
PEOPLES, AS WELL AS A DEEPENING
UNDERSTANDING OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES BEFORE US TO
DEVELOP A SHARED AGENDA. TODAY
IS THE 15TH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEXICO ADVOCACY DAY,
AND FOR 15 YEARS THIS COMMITTEE
HAS INVESTIGATED NUMEROUS ISSUES
AFFECTING OUR SHARED
CONSTITUENCIES. ON THE 15TH
ANNIVERSARY, IT IS FITTING THAT
THE SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
CALIFORNIA COOPERATION AND
DIALOG EXPLORE UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITIES TO BUILD AN AGENDA
WITH A GENDER PERSPECTIVE
THROUGH BILATERAL COOPERATION
BETWEEN OUR TWO COUNTRIES. SO
TODAY, WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
SOME DISTINGUISHED EXPERTS AND
REPRESENTATIVES WHO PROVIDE
THEIR PERSPECTIVE ON HOW
CALIFORNIA AND MEXICO CAN BUILD
AN AGENDA CENTERED AROUND TAKING
INTO ACCOUNT AND THE
PERSPECTIVES AROUND GENDER.
UNFORTUNATELY, TWO OF OUR
PANELISTS WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
MAKE IT TODAY BECAUSE OF
ILLNESS. AND WE WISH THE
GOVERNOR OF SONORA AND THE
COMMISSIONER, GARCIA BAUER, BOTH
A SPEEDY RECOVERY. DARCY TROTMAN
WILL PROVIDE A FEW REMARKS ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMISSION ON THE
STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS. BUT
BEFORE DOING SO, I'D LIKE TO
GIVE OUR ESTEEMED CONSUL GENERAL
OF MEXICO IN SACRAMENTO A
TREASURED PARTNER TO THIS
COMMITTEE, TO MYSELF AND TO THE
SENATE ON CALIFORNIA, MEXICO
ADVOCACY DAY TODAY AND BEYOND,
CONSUL CHRISTIAN GONZALEZ TO
SHARE A FEW WORDS. CONSUL,
WELCOME.
SENORA.
MUY BUENAS TARDES. A GRACIAS,
STEVE. MY DEAR FRIEND. AMIGO A
VERY STRONG ALLY TO THE
GOVERNMENT OF MEXICO, GOOD
AFTERNOON, EVERYONE. IT'S A TRUE
PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE WITH ALL OF
YOU TODAY. TODAY, TO BE PART OF
THIS IMPORTANT ANNUAL EVENT. AT
THE OUTSET, I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
DEEP GRATITUDE TO ALL OF THOSE
PRESENT, AS WELL AS TO OUR
PARTNERS IN THE SELECT COMMITTEE
FOR THE MEXICO, CALIFORNIA
COOPERATION AND DIALOG IN THE
CALIFORNIA SENATE. YOUR
COMMITMENT AND DEDICATION HAVE
BEEN CRUCIAL TO THE ONGOING
SUCCESS OF THIS DIALOG, WHICH
NOT ONLY STRENGTHENS OUR
ECONOMIC AND CULTURAL TIES, BUT
ALSO DRIVES JOINT INITIATIVES
THAT BENEFIT OUR COMMUNITIES.
FOR 15 YEARS, AS SENATOR PADILLA
HAVE MENTIONED, ADVOCACY DAY HAS
BEEN A KEY FOR STRENGTHENING THE
BONDS BETWEEN MEXICO DIALOG AND
ISSUES THAT DEEPLY AFFECT BOTH
SIDES OF THE BORDER. OVER THE
YEARS, THIS EVENT HAS SERVED AS
A FORUM FOR COLLABORATION AND
MUTUAL UNDERSTANDING BETWEEN OUR
NATIONS, AND IT HAS ALLOWED US
NOT TO ONLY REINFORCE COMMERCIAL
AND ECONOMIC CONNECTIONS, BUT
ALSO DEEPEN OUR COOPERATION IN
CRITICAL AREAS SUCH AS EDUCATION,
ENVIRONMENT AND MIGRATION.
THANKS TO THIS FORUM, WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO IDENTIFY
OPPORTUNITIES AND PROPOSE
CONCRETE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
PUBLIC POLICIES THAT BENEFIT
BOTH SIDES OF THE BORDER. THIS
YEAR, WE ARE INTENTIONALLY
FOCUSING ON THE DEVELOPMENT OF
AN INCLUSIVE GENDER AGENDA
THROUGH COLLABORATION BETWEEN
MEXICO AND CALIFORNIA. THIS
APPROACH ADDRESSES THE CURRENT
CONTEXT AND UNDERSCORES OUR
COMMITMENT TO A FEMINIST FOREIGN
POLICY THAT PROMOTES EQUITY AND
INCLUSION IN ALL ASPECTS OF OUR
SOCIETIES. IT IS CRUCIAL TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THE CHOICE OF
THIS THEME COULD NOT BE
APPROPRIATE, ESPECIALLY IF IT'S
NOT BECAUSE, AS YOU MENTIONED,
SENATOR PADILLA, THE ELECTION OF
THE PRESIDENT OF MEXICO, OF
DOCTOR DOCTOR CLAUDIA SHEINBAUM,
HER NEAR INAUGURATION TO THE
PRESIDENCY NOT ONLY WILL
RECOGNIZE THE POTENTIAL OF
FEMALE PARTICIPATION IN POLITICS
AND SOCIETY, BUT ALSO MARKS A
HISTORICAL MILESTONE AS THE
FIRST WOMAN LEADER TO ASSUME THE
PRESIDENCY IN ALL OF THE NORTH
AMERICAN REGION. HER EXEMPLARY
LEADERSHIP IN MEXICO CITY HAS
NOT ONLY INSPIRED MANY OF US,
BUT ALSO DEMONSTRATES HOW WOMEN
CAN LEAD CHANGE PARADIGMS AND
STRENGTHEN FEMALE REPRESENTATION
GLOBALLY TO INVIGORATE AND BUILD
A MORE DYNAMIC AND MEANINGFUL
COOPERATION BETWEEN MEXICO AND
CALIFORNIA, IT IS ESSENTIAL TO
IDENTIFY AREAS OF COLLABORATION,
SUCH AS THE EXCHANGE OF BEST
PRACTICES IN PUBLIC POLICY,
ORGANIZING SUMMITS AND
CONFERENCES ON GENDER EQUALITY,
AND CREATING JOINT PROGRAMS THAT
PROMOTE EDUCATION AND ECONOMICAL
EMPOWERMENT OF WOMEN. WE ALSO
EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING
BETWEEN THE MEXICAN SECRETARY OF
FOREIGN AFFAIRS AND THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION OF THE
STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS. THIS
ROBUST AND ACTIVE AGREEMENT
ADDRESSES ISSUES SUCH AS GENDER
BASED VIOLENCE, PAY GAPS, AND
UNEQUAL ACCESS TO RESOURCES AND
OPPORTUNITIES. IT REPRESENTS A
CRUCIAL STARTING POINT FOR
DRIVING BORDER ACTIONS THAT
BENEFITS THE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES, INCLUDING MEXICAN
AND INDIGENOUS WOMEN, RURAL
WOMEN, WOMEN WITH DISABILITIES
AND LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY.
BILATERAL COOPERATION BETWEEN
MEXICO AND CALIFORNIA CAN
GREATLY BENEFIT FROM ADOPTING
GENDER SENSITIVE PRINCIPLES AND
PROPOSALS. BOTH REGIONS SHARE
FUNDAMENTAL VALUES SUCH AS
EQUALITY, DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION, POSITIONING US TO
LEAD SIMILAR AGENDAS ON
INTERNATIONAL LEVEL BY WORKING
TOGETHER, MEXICO AND CALIFORNIA
NOT ONLY FOSTER MORE
COMPREHENSIVE AND EQUITABLE
POLICIES, BUT ALSO SERVE AS A
MODEL OF INTERNATIONAL
COOPERATION IN PROMOTING SOCIAL
JUSTICE, JUSTICE AND PARITY. THE
SYNERGY BETWEEN OUR REGIONS CAN
RESULT IN A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT,
CREATING MORE JUST AND EQUITABLE
SOCIETIES WHERE ALL WOMEN HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO THRIVE. ON
BEHALF OF THE GOVERNMENT OF
MEXICO, I SINCERELY THANK THE
CALIFORNIA SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEE, PARTICULARLY TO AGAIN
TO OUR FRIEND, SENATOR STEVE
PADILLA AND ALL HIS HIS HARD
WORK THAT HAVE ALLOWED US TO NOW
CREATE THIS IMPORTANT DIALOG, AS
WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE FOR THEIR PRESENCE
AND COMMITMENT TO THIS SHARED
CAUSE. MAY THIS 50TH ANNIVERSARY
OF MEXICO DAY AT THE CAPITOL BE
A RESOUNDING SUCCESS AND
STARTING POINT FOR AN EVEN
BRIGHTER AND MORE COLLABORATIVE
FUTURE BETWEEN OUR GREAT NATIONS.
SIN DUDA, ESTO ES TIEMPO DE
MUJERES. ES TIEMPO DE MINORIAS
ES TIEMPO DE MIGRANTES Y ES
TIEMPO DE CONSTRUIR UNA
SOCIEDAD. UNA COMUNIDAD MAS
FUERTE PARA TODOS PARA TODOS Y
PARA TODOS. FELIZ FELIZ DIA DE
MEXICO EN CALIFORNIA Y QUÊ. VIVA
CALIFORNIA! VIVA! VIVA MÉXICO!
MUCHAS GRACIAS. GRACIAS, CONSUL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. INSPIRING
AS ALWAYS. WE'RE GOING TO BE
JOINED TODAY BY MIGRANT SENATOR
ELECT KARINA RUIZ, WHO IS MAKING
HISTORY AS THE FIRST MEXICAN
MIGRANT TO HOLD A SEAT IN THE
MEXICAN SENATE WITH A HISTORIC
ELECTION OF THE FIRST WOMAN
PRESIDENT OF MEXICO. ALSO CAME
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR MEXICANS
ABROAD TO RECEIVE REPRESENTATION
IN THE MEXICAN GOVERNMENT. AN
ESTIMATED 12.1 MILLION MEXICANS
LIVE OUTSIDE THE COUNTRY, WITH
97% IN THE UNITED STATES,
ACCORDING TO A 2020 REPORT 21
REPORT BY THE INSTITUTE OF
MEXICANS ABROAD. IN NOVEMBER OF
2023, THE INAH ANNOUNCED REVISED
RULES. AS I NOTED EARLIER, FOR
POLITICAL PARTIES AND COALITIONS
IN ACCORDANCE, THAT REQUIRE
PARITY AND THE NOMINATION OF
PEOPLE FROM CERTAIN
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS FOR THE
FEDERAL SENATE IN MEXICO. THIS
INCLUDES AT LEAST ONE CANDIDATE
WHO WAS A MIGRANT AND RESIDENT
LIVING ABROAD, SENATOR ELECT
RUIZ IS A BENEFICIARY OF THE
DACA PROGRAM. FOR THOSE WHO
MIGRATED TO THE UNITED STATES
DURING THEIR CHILDHOOD, AND IS
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
ARIZONA DREAM ACT COALITION,
INCORPORATED. AS A MIGRANT
SENATOR, THE SENATOR ELECT HOPES
NOT ONLY TO SERVE AND LISTEN TO
MIGRANTS, BUT TO ADDRESS THEIR
THEIR NEEDS TO SEE HOW SHE CAN
HELP IMPROVE THEIR LIVES IN BOTH
COUNTRIES. AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE ARIZONA DREAM ACT
COALITION, SHE HAS WORKED ON
LISTENING, SUPPORTING PROCEDURES
AND MAKING THE DREAM OF FAMILY
REUNIFICATION COME THROUGH.
SENATOR ELECT ABOUT TO STEP INTO
A PRETTY HISTORIC ROLE.
FELICIDADES. BIENVENIDOS AND
WELCOME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATOR PADILLA, IT IS MY
PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY.
STANDING HERE IN CALIFORNIA, A
VERY DEAR PLACE TO ME. I HAVE A
MENTOR HERE, PROFESSOR ARMANDO
VASQUEZ RAMOS. HE HE HAS BEEN MY
MENTOR AND HAS BELIEVED IN ME TO
BE IN THIS POSITION. SO I WOULD
LIKE TO, MAKE THAT RECOGNITION.
I KNOW THERE'S PEOPLE IN OUR
LIVES THAT ALWAYS MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. AND I HOPE TO, IN
THE FUTURE, ALSO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN OUR LATINO AND
LATINA, GIRLS AND BOYS, TO
BELIEVE THAT THEY CAN ALSO DO
WHATEVER THEY WISH TO DO STRIVE
FOR THE STARS, AND WITH THAT,
THANK YOU SO MUCH, I WILL BE
PRESENTING. I WAS ASKED TO
PRESENT ON, ON THE TOPIC OF THE
MATTER TODAY, BUILDING AN AGENDA
WITH A GENDER PERSPECTIVE IN OUR
BILATERAL BILATERAL COOPERATION
BETWEEN MEXICO AND CALIFORNIA.
AND I CAN THINK OF A BETTER
COLLABORATION. I THINK, NEXT,
PLEASE, AS WE CAN SEE IN THE
SLIDE, AS I WAS, RESEARCHING
INTO THIS TOPIC AND RECOGNIZING
THAT MEXICO AND CALIFORNIA AND
THIS REGION HAVE A THANK YOU
HAVE A VERY IMPORTANT, NOT ONLY
ECONOMIC, TRADE, BUT, ALSO IN
MIGRATION, THIS IS THE TOPIC
THAT IS VERY DEAR TO ME. AND AS
WE CAN SEE IN THIS GRAPHIC,
CALIFORNIA AND ITS EXPORTS IN,
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS, WHEN WE
LOOKED AT OTHER PLACES IN THE
WORLD, MEXICO AND CALIFORNIA BY
FAR HAVE THE HIGHEST AMOUNT OF
EXPORTS, AND THAT TALKS ABOUT
THE ECONOMICS AND HOW IMPORTANT
IT IS FOR US TO CONTINUE THIS
COLLABORATION AS OUR COMMUNITIES
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO THRIVE
IN BOTH SIDES OF THE BORDER, AND
WE CAN SEE WOMEN ENTREPRENEURS,
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE BORDER. I
KNOW IN, IN PHOENIX, THERE IS A
PROGRAM, IN THE CONSULATE THAT
ALLOWS FOR WOMEN TO, GET THAT
LEADERSHIP SKILLS TO BE
ENTREPRENEURS AND THRIVE IN, IN,
IN THEIR BUSINESSES. I BELIEVE
THAT IS THE CASE HERE IN, IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I REALLY HOPE
FOR THAT TO BE THE CASE IN THE
WHOLE BORDER STATES. BUT BEYOND
THAT ECONOMIC IMPACT THAT WE
KNOW THAT STRONG RELATIONSHIP
THAT STATES LIKE CALIFORNIA AND
MEXICO OR AND ARIZONA AND SONORA
AND DIFFERENT OTHER BORDER
STATES HAVE, I THINK THAT TO ME,
HAVING IN MIND THE IMMIGRATION
AND THE IMPACT THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES, HAVE IN BOTH SIDES
OF THE BORDER, THAT HUMAN
MOBILITY, IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED TO CONSIDER IN ORDER TO
KEEP THIS GENDER PERSPECTIVE, IN
MIND, WOMEN THAT, HAVE SEEN
THEIR FAMILIES, SEPARATED BY A
BORDER AND OPPORTUNITIES THAT
THEY HAVE IN CALIFORNIA, MEXICAN
WOMEN IN PARTICULAR, NEXT,
PLEASE. I AM A DACA RECIPIENT,
AND I IT TOOK ME 12 YEARS TO
GRADUATE FROM ARIZONA STATE
UNIVERSITY WITH A BACHELOR OF
SCIENCE IN BIOCHEMISTRY. BECAUSE
OF MY IMMIGRATION STATUS, AS A
YOUNG LATINA, I HAVE FACED, THE
INEQUALITY IN UNIVERSITY. IN
COLLEGE, I DIDN'T SEE MANY
PEOPLE THAT SEEM LIKE ME, THAT
LOOKED LIKE ME. AND THAT WAS
VERY, VERY HARD FOR ME NOT TO BE
ABLE TO LOOK UP TO PEERS THAT
LOOK LIKE ME IN THE SCIENCES AND
HAD THAT OPPORTUNITY OF THRIVING.
AND, QUITE HONESTLY, I HAD THE
DREAM OF BECOMING A PHARMACIST
AND MAYBE A PHARMACIST PROFESSOR
TO FIND CURES TO THINGS LIKE
CANCER. THAT WAS THE WISH THAT
MY LIBRARIAN AT MY HIGH SCHOOL
HAD FOR ME. WHEN I TOLD HER I
WAS GOING FOR BIOCHEMISTRY, LIFE
TAKES US THROUGH DIFFERENT
PATHS, BUT I KNOW HOW HARD IT IS
FOR YOUNG IMMIGRANT LATINAS TO
SEE THAT BARRIER OF EDUCATION TO
KNOW THAT BECAUSE THEIR FAMILIES
ARE FROM LOW INCOME, WE DO NOT
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO STRIVE
AND ATTAIN HIGHER EDUCATION.
WITH THAT IN MIND, I THINK THAT
THIS COLLABORATION IN A
BINATIONAL AGENDA WILL HELP
LATINAS LIKE MYSELF TO BELIEVE
THAT THERE IS A DREAM OF
EDUCATION, TO KNOW THAT THERE
COULD BE COOPERATION BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA AND MEXICO. PROFESSOR
ARMANDO, THAT I MENTIONED AT THE
BEGINNING HAD THIS PROJECT WHERE
HE SAID, LET'S DO A ONE ON ONE
EXCHANGE WITH THIS, ONE ON ONE
EXCHANGE OF ONE STUDENT FROM
MEXICAN ORIGIN GOING INTO A
UNIVERSITY IN MEXICO TO EXPLORE
AND HAVE THAT INNOVATION THAT
MEXICO'S UNIVERSITIES PROVIDE,
AND SEND ONE STUDENT FROM MEXICO
TO COME HERE TO CALIFORNIA AND
ALSO GET THE BENEFIT FROM THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT HARVEST THESE
UNIVERSITIES, TO ME, TO A LATINA
LIKE MYSELF WITH DACA RIGHT NOW
AND ADVANCED PAROLE, THAT WOULD
BE AN IMMENSE OPPORTUNITY. ALSO,
THOSE FIRST AND SECOND
GENERATION, STUDENTS FROM AND
LATINAS FROM MEXICAN ORIGIN
COULD BENEFIT FROM THIS. I'M
TALKING ABOUT LATINAS, MEXICAN,
GIRL. YOUNG LADIES WOULD BE IN
COLLEGE THAT OTHERWISE WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO COME HERE BECAUSE
MAYBE THEY DO NOT HAVE THE
ECONOMIC, STANDARDS TO BE ABLE
TO PAY FOR AN EXCHANGE PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM THAT PROFESSOR
ARMANDO BROUGHT FORWARD HAS THE
INTENTION OF HAVING THE
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT PUT SOME
MONEY AND THE MEXICAN GOVERNMENT
ALSO PUTTING SOME MONEY INTO
THIS FUND TO MAKE THESE EXCHANGE
POSSIBLE, I CAN ONLY IMAGINE
WITH THE POTENTIAL OF OUR YOUNG
LATINAS AND MEXICAN YOUNG WOMEN.
HAVING THE IMPACT ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE BORDER AND HAVING THAT
EXPERIENCE FROM ACROSS THE
UNIVERSITIES. ANOTHER POTENTIAL
GROWTH IN OUR COMMUNITIES IS TO
SEE THAT PERSPECTIVE AND
DEVELOPMENT, IN OUR BORDER
COMMUNITIES, IMMIGRANTS WANT TO
INVEST IN MEXICO. THOSE
IMMIGRANTS ARE LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA. I HAVE HEARD THEY
WANT TO INVEST IN MEXICO. AND
HAVING THESE OPPORTUNITIES OF
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE TWO
STATES, I THINK, IS GOING TO
HARVEST A GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
DEVELOPMENT IN THE REGION. NEXT,
PLEASE. ALSO, THE BENEFITS, THAT
WOULD COME WITH THIS
COLLABORATION AND HAVING THIS
PERSPECTIVE OF WOMEN ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE BORDER, THOSE WOMEN
WITH DOUBLE NATIONALITY, THOSE
MEXICAN AMERICANS THAT LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA, TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THIS INCLUSION IN THE DECISION
MAKING IN THE ENTIRE REGION,
IT'S GOING TO BRING A
PERSPECTIVE THAT IS GOING TO
LIFT THOSE IN THE BOTTOM UP,
BECAUSE WE HAVE SEEN THAT
OFTENTIMES WHEN WE TALK ABOUT AN
ECONOMY THAT TRICKLES FROM THE
BOTTOM UP, IT OFTENTIMES DOESN'T
GET TO THE BOTTOM. AND WE KNOW
THAT AS MINORITIES, WE KNOW THAT
AS AS PEOPLE THAT COME FROM FROM
THE FIELDS AND THOSE WORKERS,
THAT ARE FAMILIES ARE ALWAYS
LEFT AT THE END. AND
MARGINALIZED, AS A, AS A YOUNG
WOMAN AND A DREAMER AND HAVING
THE OPPORTUNITY OF BEING THE
FIRST SENATOR OF MY COUNTRY, I
KNOW THAT THERE'S AN IMMENSE
POTENTIAL FOR WOMEN TO BE ABLE
TO LEAD AND BUILD RELATIONSHIPS
AND COLLABORATE, AND TO ME, I
MEAN, LOOKING AT, AT, AT SOME
STATISTICS BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
STATISTICS RAISE EYEBROWS RAISED
EYEBROWS. SORRY, BUT, STORIES
CHANGE MINDS. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
ALSO HAVE SOME KNOWLEDGE ABOUT
WHAT IMPACT MEXICO HAS. AND IN
THE REGION, BUT ALSO IN
CALIFORNIA. 17 WOMEN IN
CALIFORNIA STATE, STATE
LEGISLATURE. THAT'S THE AMOUNT
OF WOMEN THAT THERE IS IN THIS
STATE LEGISLATURE. AND I KNOW
THAT THESE WOMEN HAVE THE
INTEREST OF FAMILIES BECAUSE
THEY'RE CARETAKERS, BECAUSE THEY
ARE THE ONES WHO OFTENTIMES HAVE
TO, ADMINISTER, THE, THE BUDGET
AT THEIR HOMES. SO WE HAVE AN
IMMENSE POTENTIAL TO, TO MAKE
DECISIONS THAT ARE GOING TO
BENEFIT, NOT JUST A FEW, BUT ALL
OF US IN THE REGION, NEXT,
PLEASE, WHEN I ALSO THINK ABOUT
THIS PERSPECTIVE OF GENDER, I
THINK ABOUT WOMEN WHO FACE OTHER
ISSUES AT HAND. AND ONE OF THE
STATISTICS THAT JUMP OUT AT ME
WAS, THE GIRLS THAT DROP OUT OF
SCHOOL, GOING ALONG WITH WHAT I
MENTIONED ABOUT THESE,
CONTINUOUS HIGHER EDUCATION, THE
DROPOUTS IN SCHOOL, CAN, REALLY
AFFECT, THINGS IN LIFE, LIKE,
MAKING DECISIONS ABOUT HAVING A,
AN EARLY, AN EARLY PREGNANCY. TO
IMPROVE THESE, AND PURSUE A
CAREER, FOR EXAMPLE, LIKE MYSELF
IN STEM OR HIGHER EDUCATION. I
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN DO EFFORTS
IN ORDER TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT
OF, OF, YOUNG, WOMEN WHO HAVE
PREGNANCIES OR HAVE, CHILDREN AT
AN EARLY AGE. AND I WAS LOOKING
AT WHAT CALIFORNIA AND IN UNITED
STATES, WHAT EFFORTS THEY HAVE
DONE TO BRING THESE, STATISTICS
DOWN FROM 15.4 BIRTHS PER 1000
WOMEN AT AGES OF 15, DOWN TO 8%
IN 2019. AND TO ME, IT WAS
EDUCATION, EDUCATION AND
PROGRAMS THAT I MEAN, THAT'S
WHAT I WAS READING IN THESE IN
THESE EFFORTS. AND I THINK WE
CAN DO A COLLABORATION ALSO IN,
IN THAT RESPECT TO, I THINK THAT
WHEN WE, I BELIEVE THAT WHEN WE
ATTACK THE ROOT CAUSES OF
ISSUES, THEN IN THE REGION, WE
CAN ALSO HELP THESE YOUNG WOMEN
TO HAVE A CHANCE TO HIGHER
EDUCATION. AND IT'S ALL WITH IT
COMES WITH THIS INFORMATION,
WITH THIS COLLABORATION IN
PROGRAMS THAT ATTEND THOSE
POPULATIONS THAT ARE, VULNERABLE
IN THAT RESPECT, SO AGAIN, I
THINK COLLABORATION LIKE THIS
PROGRAMS THAT'S JUST AN EXAMPLE
OF WHAT THE UNITED STATES HAS
DONE AND WHAT WE CAN ALSO, BRING
ACROSS THE BORDER AND PROGRAMS
WHERE WE CAN ALSO PROMOTE IN
PLACES LIKE OUR CONSULATES, AND
DO THAT EFFORT AND THAT
COLLABORATION TOGETHER, OF
COURSE, THAT COMES WITH SOME
MONEY. AND AS I MENTIONED, THE
IDEA OF PROFESSOR ARMANDO, OF
BRINGING THESE ONE ON ONE
EXCHANGES, EVERYTHING COSTS
MONEY. SO WE NEED TO LOOK AT
OUR, OUR BUDGETS AND SEE IF WE
CAN INCLUDE THESE PROGRAMS WHERE
PEOPLE CAN ADVANCE AND THOSE
PEOPLE THAT ARE MOST AFFECTED
AND VULNERABLE, ALSO IN THE
LABOR MARKET, I'VE SEEN ALSO
THAT, MATERNITY AND PATERNITY
LEAVE. IT'S ANOTHER OF THE AREAS
WHERE WE CAN ALSO COLLABORATE.
IT MAY BE IN THINGS WHERE, IN
MEXICO, I'LL BE ADVOCATING ALSO
FOR THESE PROGRAMS FOR PEOPLE
OVER THERE AND ALSO HERE, I
WOULD LIKE TO MAYBE HEAR FROM
FROM SENATOR PADILLA ON THIS
RESPECT, ON THE ADVANCES, ON ON
PROGRAMS THAT ARE GOING TO HELP
MOTHERS AND FATHERS, THAT HAVE
CHILDREN OF, OF YOUNG AGES AND
WHAT IMPROVEMENTS CAN BE DONE. I
KNOW IN ARIZONA WE HAVE BEEN
FIGHTING FOR, MEDICAL LEAVE AND
PARENTAL LEAVE AND ALL THESE
BENEFITS, I THINK AGAIN, THE
LABOR FORCE IN BOTH OF OUR
COMMUNITIES, ALSO, THE, THE
WORKERS THAT ARE FROM MEXICAN
ORIGIN, I THINK ARE THE HARDEST,
I BELIEVE ARE THE HARDEST
WORKERS. AND OFTENTIMES WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE INTENSIFY
OUR EFFORTS TO REDUCE
INFORMALITY IN THE LABOR MARKET,
THAT WOULD GO ALONG WITH
ENSURING WOMEN AND MEN ARE FULLY
INCORPORATED INTO THE SOCIAL
PROTECTION SYSTEM AND FAIR WAGES
AND HAVE HIGHER JOB, QUALITY,
WITH THAT SAID, HAVING ME AS A,
AS A FIRST GENERATION STUDENT
AND HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY OF
REPRESENTING MY PEOPLE, AND
HAVING ALL THESE CONCERNS IN
MIND WHERE WE CAN COLLABORATE
AND COOPERATE, THAT'S JUST SOME
EXAMPLES OF THE MANY THINGS THAT
I KNOW, NEED TO BE ADDRESSED ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE BORDER. IT'S
AN HONOR FOR ME TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REPRESENT MY
PEOPLE AND FOR ME IN ORDER FOR
ALL OF US TO BE. WELL, WE HAVE
TO ATTEND THE MOST VULNERABLE.
AND IN MY COMMUNITY, THAT'S THE
UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE, THE
UNDOCUMENTED FOLKS. WORKING ON A
ON BRINGING THOSE PEOPLES OUT OF
THE SHADOW. I KNOW IN
CALIFORNIA, IT IS A WELCOMING
STATE. THE. YOU RECOGNIZE THE
VALUE OF OUR PEOPLE BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T CROSS THE BORDER MANY
TIMES IN MANY SITUATIONS, BUT
THE BORDER CROSS OUR PEOPLE. AND
WE'RE GOING TO COME HERE WITH
THIS EFFORT AND THESE SPIRIT OF
COLLABORATION. SO THAT WE CAN DO
ALL OF THESE GREAT THINGS THAT
WOULD BENEFIT PEOPLE ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE BORDER, I REALLY
BELIEVE THAT THIS TRANSFORMATION
OF OUR COUNTRY IS GOING TO,
CROSS THE BORDER AND WE'RE GOING
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR PEOPLE
FEEL THAT, FEEL THAT FROM
MEXICO. THEY RECOGNIZE THEY'RE
NOT JUST, REMESAS. BUT THEY ARE
ALSO PEOPLE THAT ARE OF MEXICAN
ORIGIN WITH WITH THEIR DIGNITY
AND THE RESPECT THAT THEY
DESERVE. WITH THAT, I AM AGAIN,
HONOR TO BE A WOMAN THAT
REPRESENTS MY PEOPLE IN THE IN
THE SENATE IN MEXICO. I KNOW
THAT IF WE WORK HARD AND IF WE
BELIEVE IN JUSTICE, WE ALWAYS
HAVE A CHANCE TO WIN. AND
COLLABORATION WITH CALIFORNIA,
IT'S IN MY HEART. AND I'LL BE
COMING BACK TO TALK TO MY
PEOPLE. AND ALSO, I'LL BE COMING
BACK TO TALK TO YOU ON OPEN
DOORS FOR THEM TO BRING THEIR
ISSUES FORWARD TO YOU. SO THAT
THEY ARE, ADDRESS IN THE BEST
WAY BECAUSE IT BENEFITS
CALIFORNIA WITH THAT. THE SAME
AS CONSUL, AS CONSUL TO NHÀ
TIÂU. VIVA MEXICO! VIVA
CALIFORNIA! THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, SENATOR.
APPRECIATE. WE'RE HONORED TO
HAVE YOU. AND YOU ARE A LIVING
WALKING EXAMPLE, NOT JUST TO
THOSE OF US THAT SHARE A COMMON
HERITAGE AND HISTORY AND OFTEN
FAMILY HISTORY, BUT TO YOUNG
WOMEN, YOUNG GIRLS EVERYWHERE ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE BORDER. AND I
THINK ALSO AN EXAMPLE OF THE
INTERDEPENDENCY AND THE
INEXTRICABLE LINK, SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC AND PERSONAL AND
CULTURAL THAT OUR TWO NATIONS
SHARE TOGETHER THAT ARE TRULY
INTERDEPENDENT. I, I OFTEN SAY
AND TO MY COLLEAGUES WHO SOME OF
THEM ARE SURPRISED THAT I'M THE
ONLY MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE, THE ONLY ONE THAT
REPRESENTS THE ENTIRE CALIFORNIA
MEXICO BORDER, FROM THE OCEAN TO
THE RIVER, AND I LOOK AT THAT AS
A TREMENDOUS HONOR, BUT ALSO A
RESPONSIBILITY. AND AND, I KNOW
I'M PREACHING TO THE CHOIR HERE,
BUT I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN COMPLEX, IS
HOW WE DEFINE AND CONVERSE
AROUND THE BINATIONAL
RELATIONSHIP, PARTICULARLY IN
THE BORDER REGION COMMUNITIES,
BECAUSE I, HAVING GROWN UP IN A
BORDER REGION COMMUNITY, I SORT
OF TOOK FOR GRANTED, ALL MY
LIFE, THE FACT THAT THERE WERE
PEOPLE WHO WERE CROSSING DAILY
THAT WERE HELPING TO BE PART OF
AN IMPORTANT ECONOMIC
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE DEPENDED
ON ON BOTH SIDES OF THE BORDER,
THAT THE ECONOMIC AND TRADE
RELATIONSHIP WITH MEXICO
STRENGTHENED. FROM THE TIME I
WAS A CHILD TO NOW MOST
IMPORTANT TRADING PARTNER,
CO-PRODUCING NORTH OF 40% OF
EXPORTS OUT OF NORTH AMERICA
WITH MEXICO, INDISPENSABLE RIGHT
ALONG WITH, HUMAN INFRASTRUCTURE
STUDENTS BEING EDUCATED ON ONE
OR BOTH SIDES OF THE BORDER,
LEARNING SKILLS THAT ARE IN
DEMAND, UNIQUELY IN THE BORDER
REGION. AND SO THERE'S THIS
IRONY, RIGHT, THAT THOSE OF US
THAT GREW UP SORT OF WITH A
SENSE OF THE BINATIONAL
RELATIONSHIP TOOK A LOT OF THAT
FOR GRANTED. AND YET THE
CONVERSATIONS, PARTICULARLY IN
RECENT TIMES, HAVE OFTEN IN
BORDER REGIONS. AND WHEN IT
COMES TO THE US AND CALIFORNIA
AND MEXICO RELATIONSHIP AND
FOCUSED ON THE CHALLENGES ONLY
OR THE PROBLEMS, AND THEN I'M
GOING TO BE BLUNT, I THINK IN
OUR RECENT POLITICAL
CONVERSATION IN THE UNITED
STATES NATIONALLY, THAT HAS BEEN
SORT OF WARPED AND TWISTED INTO
SOMETHING THAT IS WHOLLY
NEGATIVE AND ONLY NEGATIVE. SO I
THINK THAT ONE OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES AND I'D LOVE TO
GET YOUR THOUGHTS, SENATOR, ON
THIS, IS SORT OF 100,000 FOOT
LEVEL. IS THERE HAS BEEN A
NARRATIVE THAT HAS DEVELOPED
OVER MANY DECADES AND MANY YEARS
THAT SADLY, THE BORDER REGION
ITSELF AND, AND BY EXTENSION,
THE BORDER REGION AS A
REPRESENTATION OF THE BINATIONAL
RELATIONSHIP AND THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
AND MEXICO IS SOMETHING TO BE
FEARED, TO BE RUN FROM TO NOT TO
BE OVERLOOKED, AND TO BE WHOLLY
NEGATIVE. AND IN ORDER TO MOVE
GOOD POLICY AND GOOD
PARTNERSHIPS, WHETHER IT BE ON
UNDERWRITING, EDUCATIONAL
EXCHANGE OR SKILL DEVELOPMENT OR
DECIDING WHAT ARE THE CRITICAL
INDUSTRIES WE CAN HELP TOGETHER,
THE NARRATIVE IN THE
CONVERSATION HAS TO BE CORRECT
AND ACCURATE, AND IT HAS TO BE
CLEAR. SO WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS
ABOUT HOW WE CAN WORK TOGETHER
AS REPRESENTATIVES OF SORT, WHO
HAVE SOME COMMONALITY BUT ARE IN
DIFFERENT PLACES TO HELP STEER
THAT NARRATIVE TO WHAT IT TO THE
REALITIES OF THE RELATIONSHIP
TODAY, AND PARTICULARLY IN THE
BORDER REGIONS IN THE 21ST
CENTURY. RIGHT. BECAUSE WE STILL
TALK ABOUT THE US-MEXICO BORDER
REGION IN THIS COUNTRY, AS IF
IT'S BACK IN THE 19TH CENTURY,
AND WE DON'T TALK ABOUT IT FROM
A SECURITY STANDPOINT OR
ECONOMIC STANDPOINT. WE DON'T
SPEAK ABOUT THAT IN 21ST CENTURY
TERMS, AND THAT'S WHAT'S MISSING.
SO WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
HOW WE CAN LIFT THOSE VOICES AND
HOW WE CAN EDUCATE COLLEAGUES,
AND HOW I CAN BETTER EDUCATE
COLLEAGUES IN GOVERNMENT HERE TO
RESHIFT THAT CONVERSATION AROUND
THE REALITY AND NOT THE
RHETORIC. YEAH, I BELIEVE THAT
THE, THE NARRATIVE AROUND
IMMIGRATION RECENTLY, EVEN MORE
THAN, PARTICULARLY AFTER NINE,
11, IT HAS BEEN ABOUT,
CRIMINALIZING MIGRATION, ABOUT
CRIMINALIZING, FREEDOM TO MOVE
AND THE MOBILITY, I KNOW WHEN I
CAME THROUGH THE BORDER, MY
PARENTS DECIDED TO STAY. WE WERE
PLANNING TO STAY FOR ONE YEAR,
AND THEN, WE SAW HOW HARD IT WAS
TO COME. AND THEN IF WE LEFT, IT
WAS GOING TO BE HARDER TO COME
BACK. THAT MOBILITY, I THINK, IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS TO BE TALKED
ABOUT, BECAUSE I KNOW THAT IF WE
WERE GIVEN THE CHANCE TO COME
HERE IN A LEGAL WAY, WE PROBABLY
WOULD HAVE WORKED AND THEN GO
BACK TO OUR FAMILY BECAUSE WE
HAD THE REST OF OUR FAMILY IN
MEXICO, I HAVE BROTHERS THAT ARE
TEMPORARY WORKERS THAT COME HERE
SIX MONTHS, AND THEN THEY GO
BACK TO THEIR FAMILIES. BUT IF
WE KEEP HAVING THIS NARRATIVE
AND THIS CONVERSATION OF FEAR
AND PUTTING MORE BARRIERS TO
MOBILITY AND TO FACILITATING
LEGAL, MIGRATION AND MOBILITY,
WE'RE GOING TO BE FACED WITH
THESE ISSUES. I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO BRING TO THE TABLE,
ASYLUM SEEKERS, AND WE NEED TO
BRING TO THE TABLE MIGRANTS, TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS. I'VE SEEN
OFFICIAL GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS GO
TO TALK TO CBP AND TO ICE, BUT I
HAVE NOT SEEN MANY CONVERSATIONS
WITH THOSE DIRECTLY IMPACTED.
AND I THINK THAT WE DON'T HAVE
THE HUMANITY. AND IN MEXICO,
I'VE LEARNED, EVEN THOUGH I LIVE
IN PHOENIX, ARIZONA, I'VE, I'VE
TURNED TO MEXICO AND I'VE
LEARNED ABOUT A, ILLUMINISMO
MEXICANO, THE HUMANISTIC MEXICAN
WAY. AND THIS TALKS ABOUT GOING
TO THOSE THAT ARE MOST IMPACTED
TO GET THE TO GET THE BETTER
SOLUTIONS. I THINK THAT IF WE
STOP TALKING ABOUT THE GOOD
IMMIGRANT VERSUS THE BAD
IMMIGRANT, THAT NARRATIVE THAT
HAS HURT SO MANY OF OUR
FAMILIES. I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
OF TALKING TO THEN CANDIDATE,
BIDEN, PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN, AND
I ASKED HIM TO STOP THE FIRST
100 IN HIS FIRST 100 DAYS TO
STOP DEPORTATIONS. AND HE SAID,
YES, BUT NOT OF CRIMINALS. AND I
SAID, DID YOU KNOW THAT A PERSON
IS CHARGED WITH A FELONY FOR A
REENTRY BECAUSE A FATHER WAS
DEPORTED? AND THEN HE CAME BACK
TO PROVIDE FOR HIS FAMILY? HIS
ONLY CRIME WAS TO WORK. HE WAS
DEPORTED. HE CAME BACK TO
PROVIDE FOR HIS FAMILY DO, AND HE WAS
CHARGED WITH A FELONY CHARGE. HE
SAID, I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT
THOSE. AND I SAID, WELL, THAT'S
HOW MY PEOPLE IS TREATED. AND WE
I THINK WE NEED TO HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS BECAUSE WHEN HE
WAS ELECTED, HE INDEED TRIED TO
STOP A VOTE IN HIS HUNDRED DAYS
DEPORTATIONS. AND THEN WE KNOW
THE COURT PREVENTED THAT
BECAUSE, AGAIN, JUDGES ARE FAR
AWAY FROM OUR REALITIES. WE
CANNOT HELP COMMUNITIES OR FIND
THE BEST SOLUTIONS IF WE'RE
DISCONNECTED FROM THOSE THAT ARE
DIRECTLY IMPACTED. AND I KNOW
THAT I HAVE BROUGHT MY PEOPLE TO
THIS TO, TO, TO WASHINGTON, DC
TO EDUCATE, OFFICIALS. BUT I, I
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO DO MORE
OF THAT. I BELIEVE THAT WE NEED
TO HAVE OFFICIALS COME NOT JUST
TO TALK TO CBP, BUT ALSO TO WALK
TO WALK WITH THOSE MIGRANTS AND
SEE THEIR REALITIES SO THAT WE
CAN BRING TO AN UNDERSTANDING
THE BEST SOLUTIONS. BECAUSE
QUITE HONESTLY, I DON'T THINK
THAT PEOPLE SHOULD COME HERE
UNDOCUMENTED. THEY RISK THEIR
LIVES. NOBODY WANTS THAT. BUT WE
CANNOT COME TO A COMPREHENSION
OF HOW TO MAKE POLICY AND HOW TO
MAKE LAWS THAT ARE GOING TO
FACILITATE SOMETHING THAT IS
GOING TO PREVENT A FUTURE
PROBLEM, A PROBLEM AS IT IS,
PEOPLE ARE BEING UNDOCUMENTED
HERE. I WAS CAPTURING A CAGE, A
GOLDEN CAGE, BECAUSE MIGRATION
WAS NOT FACILITATED, MAYBE THE
STORY WOULD BE DIFFERENT IF THE
GOVERNMENTS WOULD AGREE TO LET
PEOPLE HAVE MOBILITY, BUT WE
WON'T KNOW UNTIL WE HAVE THOSE
THAT REPRESENT THE COMMUNITIES.
SIT DOWN WITH EVERYONE, NOT JUST
PART OF THE PROBLEM. WELL SAID.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT. AND I
THINK GOES WITHOUT SAYING TOO,
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT FOLKS WHO
ARE MOBILE AND WHO ARE
INTEGRATING, MIGRATING, WHO ARE
CONTRIBUTING TO THE ECONOMY
CRITICAL WORKFORCE, OFTEN WE
WOULDN'T FEED CALIFORNIANS AND
MOST OF THE UNITED STATES
WITHOUT A LOT OF MIGRANT LABOR,
AND WE CERTAINLY WOULDN'T DO IT
AT THE SCALE AND THE ECONOMY
THAT WE DO IT TODAY. AND IT'S
TAKEN FOR GRANTED BY A LOT OF
FOLKS IN THE UNITED STATES.
CALIFORNIA IS PROUD OF THE FACT
THAT WE GO AND TRY TO STRENGTHEN
OUR FEDERAL LAWS AROUND FAMILY
AND MEDICAL LEAVE, AROUND
RECOGNIZING THE FACT THAT WITHIN
THE MIGRANT AND INTERNATIONAL
WORKER COMMUNITY. AND THAT'S
WHAT I LIKE TO CALL THEM, A
WOMEN AS A SUBGROUP ARE
PARTICULARLY UNIQUELY
VULNERABLE. RIGHT TO OTHER
ENTERPRISES THAT TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THEIR DESIRE TO HAVE A BETTER
LIFE, AND SO WE TRY TO BUILD ON
THAT. I KNOW THAT I'VE THIS
SESSION TRIED TO BUILD, YOU
KNOW, FOCUS ON SOME SUBSETS OF
THE WORKFORCE. CERTAINLY FARM
WORKERS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
THINK ABOUT WAYS TO PROTECT
THEIR ENVIRONMENTAL REALITY. AND
THE WORK IN THE WORKPLACE AND
STRENGTHEN THOSE LAWS, AGAIN,
TRYING NOT TO LOSE SIGHT OF THE
FACT THAT WOMEN, PARTICULARLY
HERE, MAKE UP A KEY COMPONENT
AND HAVE A UNIQUE EXPERIENCE, IN
THESE DYNAMICS. AND WE CAN'T
EVER LOSE SIGHT OF THAT, AND HOW
WE WORK TOGETHER TO ADDRESS
THOSE UNIQUE NEEDS, BECAUSE
THEY'RE PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE
IN OTHER WAYS AS WELL. AND I AM
VERY PLEASED TO HEAR YOUR FOCUS
AND YOUR SPIRIT AND YOUR
DETERMINATION. I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU IN
THE FUTURE, AND I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE AND WE ALL APPRECIATE
YOUR DEDICATION AND YOUR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND YOUR PRESENCE HERE
TODAY. SO AGAIN, CONGRATULATIONS
AND THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY,
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME. APPRECIATE IT. IN A MOMENT,
WE'LL INVITE, DARCY TROUGHTON,
INTERIM EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON THE
STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS, TO
COME FORWARD. JOIN US. DARCY HAS
BUILT A NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
COMMUNICATION EFFORT, INCLUDING
AUTHORING THE COMMISSION'S AWARD
WINNING ORIGINAL RESEARCH
REPORT, CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S
ECONOMIC BLUEPRINT FOR PANDEMIC
RECOVERY. SHE'S AN EXPERT IN
SOCIAL IMPACT STRATEGIES,
ADVOCACY, AND CRISIS
COMMUNICATIONS, WITH EXPERIENCE
CENTERED IN EDUCATIONAL
LEADERSHIP, POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS,
STATE AND FEDERAL ISSUE
ADVOCACY, AND GENDER FOCUSED
PUBLIC POLICY. SHE'S PASSIONATE
ABOUT COALITION BUILDING AND
WORKING WITH INTERSECTIONAL AND
INCLUSIVE TEAMS THAT PRIORITIZE
HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES AT THE LAST MOMENT,
SHE WAS INVITED TO PROVIDE SOME
COMMENTS TO SORT OF PINCH HIT,
AS WE SAY IN A SPORTS ANALOGY,
WELCOME VERY MUCH, DIRECTOR, AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. CAN YOU
HEAR ME? THERE WE GO. THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME, SENATOR. AND
THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY IN THIS
ROOM, THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY, AND I APPRECIATE
THE INVITATION AT THE LAST
MINUTE, FILLING IN.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR OUR
COMMISSIONER, WHO COULD NOT BE
HERE TODAY, I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH YOU
SOME OF THE WORK THAT THE
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS IS DOING ON,
PARTICULARLY SOME OF THESE
ISSUES THAT CROSS BORDERS, I
ALSO WANT TO THANK ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE COME TODAY
TO SHOW SOME SUPPORT. YOU ARE,
THE COMMISSION IS IN, IN IN THE
ROOM TODAY. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT, THAT'S REFLECTED IN THAT
CALIFORNIA BLUEPRINT FOR WOMEN'S
PANDEMIC ECONOMIC RECOVERY, IS
SOMETHING THAT THE COMMISSION
HAS BEEN STUDYING FOR YEARS,
NEARLY 60 YEARS, WHICH IS THAT
WHEN WOMEN AREN'T COUNTED, WE
GENERALLY DON'T COUNT WHEN THE
TIME COMES TO MAKE KEY DECISIONS
ABOUT OUR WELL-BEING, ABOUT
PUBLIC POLICY, AND PARTICULARLY
ABOUT RESOURCE ALLOCATION. I'M
VERY PROUD TO STAND HERE TO TRY
AND STAND UP AND BE COUNTED FOR
SOME OF THE WOMEN THAT WE
REPRESENT, THAT WOULD BE 19.6
MILLION OF US, HALF THE STATE.
FOR ANYBODY UNFAMILIAR WITH OUR
WORK, THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION
ON THE STATUS OF WOMEN AND
GIRLS, WE ARE AN INDEPENDENT
STATE AGENCY, WHICH IS A LITTLE
BIT UNUSUAL. AND WE'VE SPENT 60
YEARS WORKING TO ELIMINATE
INEQUITIES IN STATE LAW AND
PRACTICES THAT AFFECT 19.6
MILLION WOMEN IN THE STATE.
THAT'S HALF THE POPULATION. AND
UNLIKE THE ENTIRE COUNTRY, WE
ARE ALSO HALF THE WORKFORCE IN
THIS STATE, PART OF OUR WORK IS
UNDERSTANDING THAT THESE SYSTEMS
OF GOVERNMENT, OF MEDIA, OF
EDUCATION, OUR WHOLE ECONOMIC
INFRASTRUCTURE, BECAUSE THEY
WEREN'T DESIGNED WITH WOMEN'S
PARTICIPATION IN MIND ORIGINALLY,
THEY DON'T FULLY SERVE US,
DESPITE THE RECENT EFFORTS OF
THE LAST 50 OR 60 YEARS.
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING IS GENDER
NEUTRAL. AND IT CAN'T BE MADE
GENDER NEUTRAL WITHOUT
SIGNIFICANT STRUCTURAL CHANGES.
SO THAT IS OUR FOCUS IS ON
CHANGING THE ACTUAL STRUCTURES
WE TRY TO LEAD WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT WOMEN'S
EXPERIENCES ALSO REFLECT THE
INTERSECTIONAL NATURE OF OUR
LIVES, OUR RACE OR ETHNICITY,
IMMIGRANT STATUS, SEXUAL
ORIENTATION, DISABILITY STATUS,
STATUS AS PARENTS, ALL OF THOSE
THINGS COLLIDE WITH EXISTING
INEQUITIES EXPERIENCED BY
EVERYONE WHO SHARES OUR GENDER.
IT CREATES LAYERS OF INEQUALITY
AND DISCRIMINATION AGAINST WHICH
WE NEED TO COLLABORATE AND TO
WORK IN SOLIDARITY IN ORDER TO
CHALLENGE THOSE AND OVERCOME. WE
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT OUR
INDIVIDUAL EXPERIENCES ARE BOUND
UP IN EACH OTHER'S NÓ WOMAN IS
FREE. WHILE ANY OF US ARE STILL
FIGHTING SYSTEMS OF OPPRESSION,
AND NONE OF OUR SYSTEMS WERE
DESIGNED FOR US TO BE FULL,
EQUAL PARTICIPANTS UNTIL WE ARE
ALL RECOGNIZED EQUALLY, WE ALL
HAVE WORK TO DO. OUR 17 MEMBER
COMMISSION INCLUDES THREE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS, THREE OF YOUR
SENATE COLLEAGUES, NINE PUBLICLY
APPOINTED MEMBERS, AND THE
STATUTORILY ASSIGNED CALIFORNIA
LABOR COMMISSIONER WHO
UNFORTUNATELY COULD NOT BE HERE
TODAY. THE WORK INVOLVES
APPLYING AN INTERSECTIONAL
GENDER LENS. WHEN WE TAKE THAT
GENDER LENS APPROACH FROM THE
WOMEN, PEACE AND SECURITY,
POLICIES PASSED IN 2017, AND
APPLYING THAT GENDER LENS TO
STATE POLICY AND PRACTICE, AND
TRYING TO IDENTIFY WHERE AND HOW
SPECIFIC STRUCTURAL IMPROVEMENTS
CAN BE MADE TO ENSURE MORE
EQUITABLE OUTCOMES IN 2021, WE
WERE HONORED TO WORK WITH THE
MINISTRY OF FOREIGN AFFAIRS, THE
UNITED MEXICAN STATES CONSUL
GENERAL, AND ENACT THAT
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING
REFERENCED EARLIER THAT
RECOGNIZES SPECIFICALLY THAT
WOMEN ARE CRITICAL AGENTS OF
CHANGE AND THAT THROUGH OUR
COMMITTED POLITICAL
PARTICIPATION, NOT JUST OUR ROLE
IN OUR FAMILIES. WE CAN MOVE
ACTUAL MOUNTAINS. WE'VE AGREED
TO EXPAND OUR COOPERATION IN THE
PROMOTION OF GENDER EQUITY AND
WOMEN'S EMPOWERMENT TO HELP
WOMEN FULFILL THEIR PERSONAL AND
PROFESSIONAL POTENTIAL,
PARTICULARLY IN THE FACE OF
BARRIERS SUCH AS ASSAULT AND
HARASSMENT, A LACK OF ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND HEALTH
CARE, A LACK OF ACCESS TO
QUALITY EDUCATION, AND
PERSISTENT RACIALIZED WEALTH
GAPS. THE COMMISSION SPENT A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TIME ON
THAT LAST PIECE, AND IT WAS
THEN, AND REMAINS NOW, OUR GOAL
TO ENGAGE IN MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL
ACTIVITIES THAT PROMOTE
INTERSECTIONAL GENDER EQUITY IN
THE WORKPLACE, AT HOME AND IN
SOCIETY. AT LARGE. THIS REQUIRES
US TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IN
CALIFORNIA, LOW WAGE SERVICE
SECTOR EMPLOYEES WHO WE'VE BEEN
CALLING ESSENTIAL FOR THE LAST
FOUR YEARS, REMAIN LARGELY
OCCUPATIONALLY SEGREGATED, WITH
LATINAS IN PARTICULAR MAKING UP
70% OF THAT WORKFORCE IN SOME
INDUSTRIES. IT REQUIRES US TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THEY ARE
EARNING $0.49 FOR EVERY DOLLAR
EARNED BY WHITE MEN IN THE
STATE, AND THAT LATINAS WITH A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE ARE EARNING
JUST $0.58 FOR EVERY DOLLAR
EARNED BY WHITE MEN. EDUCATION
IS NOT THE GREAT EQUALIZER THAT
WE NEED IT TO BE. IT ALSO MEANS
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT WE HAVE A LOT
OF WORK LEFT TO DO, EVEN AS WE
ARE WATCHING A WOMAN RUN FOR THE
HIGHEST OFFICE IN THE LAND AND
WE ARE STEPS FROM FINALLY
ACHIEVING PARITY IN OUR STATE
LEGISLATURE, THERE'S A LOT THAT
HAS REMAINED UNCHANGED. WE ALSO
HAVE TO LOOK AT THAT PAY GAP IN
TERMS OF OTHER FACTORS, RIGHT?
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT, YEARS OF
WORK EXPERIENCE, OCCUPATION,
INDUSTRY, CITIZENSHIP,
CITIZENSHIP, STATUS. THEY
EXPLAIN. ALTHOUGH DO NOT JUSTIFY
ONLY SOME OF THOSE
DISCREPANCIES, THERE IS A
REMAINING GAP NOT EXPLAINED BY
ANY OF THOSE FACTORS. OH I
FORGOT PARENTHOOD. THAT ONE.
THAT ONE GETS IN THERE TOO. BUT
THERE IS A REMAINING GAP NOT
EXPLAINED BY ANY OF THOSE
FACTORS THAT SAYS THAT OVER A 40
YEAR CAREER, THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WHAT A CALIFORNIA LATINA
IS GOING TO EARN AND WHAT A
WHITE MAN IS GOING TO EARN, IS
GOING TO COST THAT WOMAN $2.1
MILLION. THAT'S A WHOLE
RETIREMENT. THAT'S A WHOLE
FAMILY'S SECURITY. AND SUPPORT.
AND WHEN WE START LOOKING AT
THESE THINGS THROUGH ALL OF
THESE MULTIPLE INTERSECTIONAL
LENSES, WE HAVE TO ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WOMEN DO NOT
HAVE THE SAME EXPERIENCE. RIGHT?
IT IS DEEPLY RACIALIZED. IT IS
ALSO DEEPLY, INCONSISTENT HAVING
TO DO WITH PARENTHOOD STATUS,
DISABILITY AND LGBTQ STATUS.
COLLECTIVELY, WOMEN IN
CALIFORNIA ARE LOSING
APPROXIMATELY $87 BILLION
ANNUALLY TO THE GENDER PAY GAP
ALONE, AND UNFORTUNATELY,
LATINAS ARE BURDENED WITH MOST
OF THAT ECONOMIC SHORTFALL. IT
HITS THEM THE HARDEST, ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THAT BLUEPRINT
FOUND IS THAT IF WE SIMPLY PAID
WORKING WOMEN THE SAME AS MEN,
WE WOULD REDUCE POVERTY FOR
WORKING WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA BY
40%. THIS IS A MASSIVE REDUCTION.
ALL WE HAVE TO DO IS PAY THEM
WHAT WE PAY THEM IN, IN THE
EXACT SAME JOBS THEY'RE
CURRENTLY IN. NO OTHER CHANGE.
AND YET, DESPITE THAT, THERE'S A
LOT TO BE PROUD OF IN THIS
STATE. WOMEN OWN MOST OF THE
SMALL BUSINESSES. WE ARE
INCREDIBLE ENTREPRENEURS. YES,
WE ARE MOTHERS. YES, WE ARE
OFTEN VICTIMS, BUT WE ARE ALSO
CREATIVE. WE ARE HARD WORKING
AND WE ARE BUSINESS MINDED AND
WE CONTRIBUTE ENORMOUSLY TO OUR
SHARED COLLECTIVE ECONOMIC
GROWTH AND SUCCESS. IN THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY OF THE WORLD,
CALIFORNIA IS ACTUALLY HOME TO
THE MOST LATINO OWNED SMALL
BUSINESSES IN THE ENTIRE NATION
WHO CONTRIBUTE MORE THAN $9
BILLION TO THE ECONOMY EVERY
SINGLE YEAR. AND I WANT TO JUST
ASK THIS ROOM TO IMAGINE WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IF WE STARTED
INVESTING IN THOSE WOMEN AND
THOSE COMPANIES THE WAY WE DO
YOUNG MEN WITH TECH STARTUPS
LIVING IN THEIR PARENTS GARAGES,
AND HOW MANY APPLES AND TESLAS
AND MICROSOFTS? WE HAVEN'T
RECOGNIZED SIMPLY BECAUSE THEIR
FOUNDERS LOOKED A LITTLE
DIFFERENT. OR WHEN THEY WENT TO
APPLY FOR A BANK LOAN, THEY HAD
TWO KIDS IN TOW AND THEIR PAPERS
WERE WRINKLED. MOST OF THOSE
SMALL BUSINESSES REPRESENT
ATTEMPTS TO MAKE ENDS MEET IN
THE FACE OF EXTREME PAY
INEQUITIES AND THE POVERTY THAT
COMES WITH IT. IF WE'RE GOING TO
CELEBRATE THE SUCCESS OF OUR
BUSINESSES, WE ALSO HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THEY'RE DRIVEN BY
NECESSITY AS MUCH AS BY PASSION.
THAT'S A CHALLENGE FOR EVERYBODY
IN THIS ROOM TO SOLVE. IT IS OUR
COLLECTIVE PROBLEM, AND THIS IS
BEFORE WE EVEN BEGIN TO ADDRESS
THE NEEDS AND PERSISTENT
CHALLENGES FACED BY LABOR
FORCES, SUCH AS MIGRANT WORKERS
WHO ARE ESSENTIAL TO BRINGING
NEARLY HALF OF THE NATION'S FOOD
TO OUR TABLES EVERY DAY, FOR
EXAMPLE, OR THE PERSISTENTLY
UNDERPAID SERVICE WORKERS
WITHOUT WHOM ENTIRE INDUSTRIES
THAT OUR ECONOMY RELIES ON
ABSOLUTELY DO Ã COLLAPSE COVID
19 SHUTDOWNS DRASTICALLY SHIFTED
THE BURDENS OF CAREGIVING TO OUR
HOMES, ESPECIALLY ON THE
SHOULDERS OF WOMEN. THE PANDEMIC
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED THE
SHARE OF WOMEN'S LABOR AT HOME,
EVEN FOR THOSE STILL WORKING
FULL TIME AND WOMEN EMPLOYED IN
THE CARE INDUSTRY WERE
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED. THIS
HASN'T CHANGED EVEN FOUR YEARS
INTO A PANDEMIC. MOREOVER, WOMEN
IN CARE PROFESSIONS,
PARTICULARLY CHILD CARE, SUFFER
FROM PERSISTENT INEQUALITY,
MAKING ON AVERAGE SALARIES THAT
ARE COMPARABLE WITH THOSE EARNED
BY DOG WALKERS IN AMERICA,
THEY'RE AVERAGING ABOUT $12 AN
HOUR, WHICH IN CALIFORNIA IS
LESS THAN FAST FOOD. IT IS A
STATEMENT ABOUT WHAT WE THINK OF
THE VALUE OF THEORETICALLY
WOMEN'S WORK. AND GENDER, IT
TURNS OUT, IS A SUBSTANTIVE
ELEMENT THAT MUST BE CONSIDERED
IN THE HEALTH OF ANY OVERALL
WORKFORCE. AND OUR CONTINUED
CAPACITY FOR ECONOMIC GROWTH AND
GLOBAL COMPETITIVENESS. IT THE
COMMISSION IS CONCERNED BY THE
SYSTEMIC EROSION OF WOMEN'S
WELL-BEING, HUMAN RIGHTS AND
ECONOMIC STATUS THAT WE'VE BEEN
SEEING IN RECENT YEARS. AND I
APPRECIATED THE NOD TO SOME OF
THE HARMFUL RHETORIC,
PARTICULARLY AROUND BORDER
SECURITY, AND SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT HAVE ARISEN
BECAUSE OF THAT RHETORIC. WE
ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT THAT
THIS HAS ON WOMEN OF COLOR
ACROSS THE BOARD. LGBTQIA WOMEN,
MIGRANT FEMALE WORKERS,
FAMILIES, AND THEN WOMEN AS A
WHOLE. BECAUSE AS I KEEP SAYING,
WE'RE ALL IN IT TOGETHER, AND
I'M GLAD FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE THESE REMARKS TODAY AND TO
DOUBLE DOWN ON THE COMMISSION'S
COMMITMENT TO A RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND MEXICO
THAT PRIORITIZES GENDER EQUITY
RIGHT AT THE TOP AND THE NEEDS
OF WOMEN AND GIRLS, AND OUR
COMMITMENT TO BUILDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WOMEN AND
GIRLS, AND TO RAISING AWARENESS
FOR THE IMPORTANCE OF ADOPTING
THIS SORT OF INTERSECTIONAL
GENDER PERSPECTIVE WITHIN
POLICYMAKING, WITHIN THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY, WITHIN HOW
WE INVEST IN OUR FUTURE, AND TO
ENCOURAGE CONTINUED COOPERATION
ON JOINT PROJECTS THAT ADDRESS
SPECIFICALLY THE ECONOMIC
CHALLENGES WE FACE AS WELL AS
OUR SOCIAL CHALLENGES. AND WITH
YOUR SUPPORT AND THE SUPPORT OF
THE LEGISLATURE, IT'S OUR HOPE
THAT WE'LL BUILD ON OUR EXISTING
MOU TO CONTINUE TO DEVELOP
MEANINGFUL POLICY, TO MITIGATE
THOSE CHALLENGES, AND TO OPEN A
BROADER FUTURE OF OPPORTUNITY,
PARTICULARLY FOR GIRLS. THE
POPULATION OF CALIFORNIA IS
CHANGING, AND GIRLS ARE
ABSOLUTELY OUR FUTURE. I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY TO
MAKE A FEW REMARKS, AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO MANY MORE YEARS OF
COOPERATION AND CONTINUED
PRODUCTIVE DIALOG. AND IT IS MY
HOPE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO ONE DAY
CELEBRATE NOT NEEDING TO HAVE
THESE CONVERSATIONS ANYMORE,
BECAUSE WE WILL HAVE DONE IT.
THANK YOU. VERY WELL PUT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, DARCY. AND JUST A
NOTE, THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS. THEY'RE WELL TAKEN AND
I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE WORK
OF THE COMMISSION AND HAVE FOR
MANY DECADES, FRANKLY, I WILL
JUST SAY THIS AS WELL, FOR THE
RECORD, SO THAT, YOU KNOW, AS
YOU SIT UP HERE AND LOOK AT A
CISGENDERED MALE WITH THE STAFF
SITTING UP HERE HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE PLACE OF
THE UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE OF GENDER
LENS HERE. AND I WANTED TO BE
CLEAR, I HAVE A COUPLE OF
DISTINGUISHED COLLEAGUES WHO SIT
ON THIS SELECT COMMITTEE WHO ARE
AMAZING WOMEN LEADERS AND WHO
SEND THEIR REGRETS BECAUSE THEY
GOT PULLED AWAY AND WERE ABLE TO
SIT ON THE HEARING. AND ALSO,
YOU KNOW, SENATOR LIMÓN, WHO IS
A FRIEND AND A COLLEAGUE, SITS
ON THE COMMISSION, ALSO INTENDS
TO INTENDED TO TRY TO SWING BY
AT SOME POINT. AND I KNOW THAT
AS I MENTIONED AT THE TOP OF THE
HEARING, THERE ARE SOME
EXTRANEOUS CIRCUMSTANCES AND
MOVEMENTS AND SCHEDULE CONFLICTS
THAT ARE HAPPENING IN REAL TIME
THAT WE DON'T HAVE CONTROL OVER.
SO I WANTED TO BE SURE THAT ALL
OF OUR DISTINGUISHED, WOMEN
PARTICIPANTS AND GIRLS WHO MAY
BE WATCHING. IT IS NOT MEANT IN
ANY WAYS DISRESPECTFUL OR BLIND
THING. I HAD HOPED TO BE JOINED
BY SOME DISTINGUISHED WOMEN
COLLEAGUES UP HERE TODAY, AND
JUST THE GODS DIDN'T ALLOW THAT
TO HAPPEN TODAY. BUT WE WILL
SOLDIER ON, BECAUSE THE CONTENT
OF THIS CONVERSATION IS
IMPORTANT. AND DARCY, I DO AGREE
WITH YOU THAT I THINK WE ALL ARE
TRYING TO WORK TOWARDS,
SOMETHING THAT WE HOPE THAT
THESE CONVERSATIONS, WHICH
SOMETIMES SEEM SO RUDIMENTARY
AND OBVIOUS, IT SHOULD SHOULD BE
OBVIOUS, WILL NOT BE NECESSARY.
AND YOU CAN COUNT THIS MEMBER IN
AMONG THOSE WHO DESIRE THAT. SO
I WANTED TO PUT THAT ON THE
RECORD. FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
WONDERING WHAT IS GOING ON HERE,
THIS DIALOG, AND SO THAT YOU
KNEW WHAT WAS GOING ON. AND
AGAIN, THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT. IT'S MY PLEASURE TO
WELCOME NATALIA VEGA, POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR GENDER EQUITY
POLICY INSTITUTE, INVITE YOU TO
COME FORWARD. NATALIA HAS A
BACKGROUND IN INTERNATIONAL
DEVELOPMENT, DEVELOPMENT POLICY,
MACROECONOMICS AND FEMINIST
ECONOMIC ANALYSIS, HAS
COLLABORATED WITH VARIOUS
INTERNATIONAL INSTITUTIONS,
INCLUDING THE UNITED NATIONS
DEPARTMENT OF. ECONOMIC AND
SOCIAL AFFAIRS, AS WELL AS
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS
THE WOMEN'S ENVIRONMENTAL AND
DEVELOPMENT ORGANIZATION THAT
ADVOCATE FOR GENDER EQUITY AND
CLIMATE CHANGE AWARENESS.
NOTABLY, SHE HAS AUTHORED DOUBLE
DISADVANTAGE UNDOCUMENTED WOMEN
IN THE UNITED STATES, AN
IN-DEPTH ANALYSIS OF
UNDOCUMENTED WOMEN IN THE US
WITH A PARTICULAR FOCUS ON THE
FOUR STATES WITH THE HIGHEST
NUMBERS OF UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS CALIFORNIA, TEXAS,
FLORIDA, AND NEW YORK. AND WE
EXTEND A WARM WELCOME TO YOU,
NATALIA. CAN YOU HEAR ME? THANK
YOU, SENATOR PADILLA. AND I WANT
TO THANK THE DISTINGUISHED
GUESTS THAT ARE HERE IN THE
ROOM. I'M DEEPLY HONORED TO BE
PART OF THE DISCUSSION, AS A
PROUD LATINA FROM MEXICO, I'M
HONORED TO BE PART OF THE
DISCUSSION OF BUILDING AN AGENDA
WITH A GENDER PERSPECTIVE
THROUGH BINATIONAL COOPERATION
BETWEEN MEXICO AND CALIFORNIA AT
THE GENDER EQUITY POLICY
INSTITUTE, WE ACCELERATE GENDER
EQUALITY THROUGH RESEARCH,
ADVOCACY, AND POLICY
DEVELOPMENT. WE SPECIALIZE IN
INTERSECTIONAL GENDER IMPACT
ANALYSIS AND ARE THE FIRST US
ORGANIZATION DEVOTED TO GENDER
MAINSTREAMING. CALIFORNIA AND
MEXICO SHARE A UNIQUE
GEOGRAPHICAL AND CULTURAL
CLOSENESS AND THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE FACE OFTEN THAT WE FACE
OFTEN TRANSCEND OUR BORDERS. TWO
OF THE MOST PRESSING ISSUES ARE
GENDER EQUITY AND CLIMATE
CHANGE, WHICH REQUIRE
COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS AND
INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS. TODAY, I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT ABOUT HOW
EMPOWERING LATINAS CAN ADVANCE
EQUITY AND CLIMATE GOALS IN BOTH
REGIONS. FIRST, I WILL PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW OF THE CURRENT STATE
OF LATINAS IN CALIFORNIA,
HIGHLIGHTING THEIR PROGRESS,
ENORMOUS CONTRIBUTIONS, AND
UNIQUE CHALLENGES. NEXT, I WILL
EXAMINE THE INTERSECTION OF
GENDER AND CLIMATE CHANGE. AS
MANY OF US KNOW, CLIMATE CHANGE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS
WOMEN, ESPECIALLY THOSE FROM
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES.
LATINOS ARE NO EXCEPTION AND ARE
PARTICULARLY AFFECTED AS A
COMMUNITY. FINALLY I'LL SHARE
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS TO HELP
INCORPORATE A GENDER PERSPECTIVE
IN TACKLING CLIMATE CHANGE. THIS
POLICY IS AIMED TO EMPOWER
LATINAS IN CALIFORNIA AND
MEXICO, WHILE ENSURING THAT OUR
EFFORTS ARE FAIR AND EFFECTIVE.
MANY OF THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
CAN SERVE AS FIRST STEPS FOR
KNOWLEDGE SHARING AND
COLLABORATION ACROSS BORDERS.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. SO TO FIRST
UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN EMPOWER
LATINAS IN CALIFORNIA, WE MUST
KNOW WHO THEY ARE. WHILE THEY
PLAY A CRUCIAL ROLE IN THE
STATE'S ECONOMY AND SOCIETY. 2
IN 5 CALIFORNIA WOMEN AND GIRLS
ARE LATINAS. MAJORITY OF THEM
WERE BORN IN CALIFORNIA.
ALTHOUGH A SIGNIFICANT SHARE ARE
IMMIGRANTS, WITH A QUARTER OF
THEM BEING BORN IN MEXICO.
THEY'RE WOMEN WHO TEND TO BE
YOUNGER, WITH A MEDIAN AGE OF 31
YEARS OLD, AND THEY'RE MORE
LIKELY TO BE MOTHERS WITH ABOUT
1 IN 4 OF THEM BEING MOTHERS OF
CHILDREN UNDER 18. NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. THEY CONTRIBUTE
ENORMOUSLY TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY. THEY HAVE A HIGH
PARTICIPATION IN THE LABOR FORCE
THAT DRIVES VARIOUS SECTORS
ACROSS THE STATE. ABOUT 1 IN 5
LATINAS AGED 25 AND OLDER HOLD A
BACHELOR'S DEGREES, WHICH SHOWS
HOW THEY'RE ENHANCING THEIR
ECONOMIC PROSPECTS AND
LEADERSHIP POTENTIAL. LATINO
OWNED BUSINESSES ARE ALSO KEY
PLAYERS IN LOCAL ECONOMIC
GROWTH, GENERATING NEARLY
147,000 JOBS IN CALIFORNIA.
THEY'RE ESSENTIAL CONTRIBUTORS
TO CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE.
THEY'RE CASHIERS, MAIDS,
PERSONAL CARE AIDES, RETAIL
SALESPERSON AND CUSTOMER SERVICE
REPRESENTATIVES ALL OCCUPATIONS
THAT WE KNOW THAT THEY TEND TO
BE LOW WAGE BUT ARE VITAL TO
CALIFORNIA'S TOP INDUSTRIES.
EVEN AMONG UNDOCUMENTED WOMEN IN
CALIFORNIA, 11% WORK AS MAIDS,
SHOWING HOW THEY MAKE CRUCIAL
CONTRIBUTIONS DESPITE THEIR
CHALLENGING CIRCUMSTANCES. NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. YET DESPITE BEING
ESSENTIAL WORKERS, LATINOS IN
CALIFORNIA FACE MANY ECONOMIC
CHALLENGES. THEY'RE OFTEN
CONCENTRATED IN SERVICE AND CARE
WORK OCCUPATIONS. AND AS YOU CAN
SEE IN THE SLIDE, THEY'RE LOW
PAID. AS A RESULT, THEY HAVE THE
LOWEST MEDIAN INCOME AMONG RACE
AND ETHNICITY GROUPS. THEIR
SALARIES TYPICALLY RANGE FROM
25,000 TO $32,000 PER YEAR. ALL
OF THESE CHALLENGES, WHEN YOU
ADD WHEN YOU ADD ALL OF THESE
CHALLENGES, HALF OF LATINOS LIVE
IN RENTED HOMES AND THE MAJORITY
OF WOMEN LED HOUSEHOLDS CANNOT
AFFORD TO EVEN PAY THEIR RENT.
THEY'RE ALSO AMONG THE LEAST
LIKELY TO HAVE HEALTH INSURANCE
IN THE STATE. ALL OF THESE
ECONOMIC CHALLENGES ARE AND WILL
BE EXACERBATED BY CLIMATE CHANGE.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. SO IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
CLIMATE CHANGE IS A WOMEN'S
ISSUE. RESEARCH DEMONSTRATES
THAT WOMEN ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY SUFFERING THE
HARMS AND IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE, SO MUCH SO THAT THE
UNITED NATIONS FRAMEWORK
CONVENTION ON CLIMATE CHANGE HAS
CREATED A GENDER ACTION PLAN TO
BE INCORPORATED IN EVERY CLIMATE
ACTION. SO THERE'S ENOUGH
EVIDENCE THAT SUPPORTING GENDER
EQUITY AND ENSURING THAT WOMEN
FULLY PARTICIPATE IN CREATING A
CLIMATE RESILIENT ECONOMY CAN
SIGNIFICANTLY HELP CALIFORNIA
AND MEXICO AND MEXICO ACHIEVE
THEIR CLIMATE GOALS. NOW, THE
REASONS BEHIND THIS
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ARE
TWOFOLD. FIRST, WOMEN GENERALLY
HAVE FEWER RESOURCES FOR
RESPONSE AND RESILIENCE. THEY
SPEND HIGHER SHARES OF THEIR
INCOME ON ENERGY AND HOUSING,
AND THEY HAVE TO FACE THE GENDER
PAY GAPS, MEANING THAT THEY'RE
EARNING LESS THAN MEN. SECOND,
WOMEN HAVE GREATER CARE BURDENS
WHEN THERE ARE CLIMATE RELATED
DISASTERS. IT IS WOMEN WHO BEAR
THE BRUNT OF CARING FOR THE
VULNERABLE. ALSO, MANY OF THEM
WORK IN PAID CAREGIVING JOBS,
WHICH OBVIOUSLY ADDS TO THEIR
BURDEN. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. SO
HOW ARE LATINAS IN CALIFORNIA
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
CLIMATE CHANGE? WELL, WE HAVE A
REPORT THAT'S CALLED THE PROMISE
OF GENDER INCLUSIVE CLIMATE
ACTION THAT EXPLORES THIS MORE
IN DEPTH. BUT I WILL GIVE SOME
EXAMPLES. FIRSTLY, LATINO
HOUSEHOLDERS EXPERIENCE ENERGY
BURDENS SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
THAN THE STATEWIDE AVERAGE,
MEANING THAT THEY'RE SPENDING
MORE OF THEIR INCOME IN
CLEANING, IN PAYING FOR
ELECTRICITY AND GAS OR FUEL,
SECONDLY, MOST LATINOS LIVE IN
REGIONS LIKE LOS ANGELES, THE
INLAND EMPIRE AND SAN DIEGO,
WHERE EXTREME HEAT IS
INTENSIFYING. THIRDLY, LATINOS
ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE BURDENED
BY HOUSEHOLD AND CARE
RESPONSIBILITIES COMPARED TO
OTHER WOMEN. IN THIS SLIDE, I
THINK IT SAYS THAT THEY SPEND
OVER FIVE HOURS IN HOUSEHOLD AND
CAREGIVING ACTIVITIES. THAT IS
PER DAY, AND FINALLY, THEY'RE
MORE LIKELY TO LIVE IN AREAS
WITH POOR QUALITY WATER AND
SUFFER FROM DROUGHT CONDITIONS.
ALL OF THIS VULNERABILITIES,
ALONG WITH LIVING IN INADEQUATE
HOUSING CONDITIONS, EXACERBATE
LATINOS CLIMATE VULNERABILITY.
SO WHAT KIND OF POLICIES CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED TO PROMOTE LATINOS
TO PROMOTE EQUITY FOR LATINOS
WHILE ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE?
THANK YOU, WELL, ONE IS, I'LL
GIVE SOME RECOMMENDATIONS, BUT
THERE ARE MANY RECOMMENDATIONS
I'M JUST GIVEN THREE FOR NOW,
ONE IS TO INCREASE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AMONG LATINO LED
HOUSEHOLDS TO HELP ADDRESS THEIR
HIGH ENERGY BURDENS. NOW, HOW
CAN WE DO THIS? IS. WELL,
THERE'S EVIDENCE THAT WOMEN,
PARTICULARLY THOSE IN LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS, DO NOT FULLY TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF WEATHERIZATION AND
ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS. SO
THERE'S AN EVIDENT NEED TO
IMPLEMENT TARGETED OUTREACH THAT
CAN INCREASE THEIR PARTICIPATION
IN THESE TYPE OF PROGRAMS.
SECONDLY, BY MITIGATING URBAN
HEAT ISLAND EFFECTS, HOW WE CAN
HOW CAN WE DO THIS? WELL, ONE
EXAMPLE IS BY EXPANDING THE USE
OF COOLING MATERIALS IN URBAN
PAVEMENTS. THIS WILL NOT ONLY
IMPROVE COMMUNITY RESILIENCE,
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS,
BUT IT WILL ALSO BENEFIT LATINOS
WHO FREQUENTLY SPEND TIME
OUTDOORS BECAUSE OF THEIR
OCCUPATIONS AND THEIR CARE
RESPONSIBILITIES AND FINALLY
INVESTING IN ROBUST PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
MANY OF US KNOW THAT WOMEN ARE
THE MAJORITY OF PUBLIC TRANSIT
USERS, AND THAT PROMOTING THE
USE OF PUBLIC TRANSIT IS A GREAT
POLICY TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. SO WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT PUBLIC TRANSIT IS SAFE,
ACCESSIBLE AND CATERS TO WOMEN'S
NEEDS. THAT WAY, GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS WILL BE REDUCED, A
GREATER USE OF TRANSIT WILL BE
ENCOURAGED AND ESPECIALLY AMONG
ESPECIALLY AMONG LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND EQUITY OVERALL
WILL BE IMPROVED. NOW, THESE
POLICIES CAN BE THE FIRST STEPS
TOWARDS BUILDING A BILATERAL
AGENDA BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND
MEXICO. AND I THINK IT'S A GREAT
EXAMPLE OF HOW WE CAN ADDRESS
URGENT ISSUES, ISSUES LIKE
CLIMATE CHANGE WHILE
INCORPORATING A GENDER
PERSPECTIVE. BUT I ALSO WANT TO
GIVE SOME RECOMMENDATIONS OF HOW
THIS BILATERAL COOPERATION COULD
BE BUILT THROUGH. NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. IT COULD BE BY
COLLABORATING ON RESEARCH
INITIATIVES AND SHARING DATA TO
UNDERSTAND, UNDERSTAND BETTER
AND ADDRESS THE GENDER IMPACTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE. WORKING
TOGETHER TO CREATE POLICIES THAT
INTEGRATE GENDER CONSIDERATIONS
AND PROMOTE EFFECTIVE CLIMATE
ACTION AND FINALLY FACILITATING
THE EXCHANGE OF TECHNOLOGIES AND
INNOVATIVE PRACTICES TO ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE AND IMPROVE
EQUITY. SO WITH THIS, I'VE
HIGHLIGHTED HOW IMPLEMENTING A
GENDER PERSPECTIVE WE CAN
EMPOWER LATINAS WHILE MAKING
SIGNIFICANT STRIDES IN BOTH
EQUITY AND CLIMATE RESILIENCE. I
WANT TO ENCOURAGE ALL OF US TO
CONTINUE THIS VITAL
COLLABORATION AND IMPLEMENT
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS TO ENSURE
A BETTER FUTURE FOR ALL, I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION, AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
OUR CONTINUED EFFORTS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
NATALIA VERY INFORMATIVE AND
APPRECIATE THE LENS ON
RESILIENCY AROUND THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE IN REAL TIME, IN
REAL TERMS. I SEE IT EVERY DAY
AND I LIVE, YOU KNOW, IN THE
DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT ACROSS
THE SPECTRUM AND THE COASTAL
AREAS OF MY COMMUNITY. THE
CLIMATE CHANGE HAS WORKED TO
EXACERBATE THE SWELLING OF THE
TIJUANA RIVER WATERSHED AT
TIMES, WHICH ITSELF THEN
COMPLICATES ISSUES AROUND TRYING
TO MITIGATE THOSE FLOWS FROM A
PUBLIC HEALTH STANDPOINT
PERSPECTIVE. AND SO AND THE
COMMUNITIES, OF COURSE, THAT ARE
VERY VULNERABLE THERE ARE OFTEN
WOMEN, LATINO WOMEN IN THAT PART
OF THE STATE WHO ARE ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE BORDER. FRANKLY AND
WE SEE THAT IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
AREAS AS I GO, MY DISTRICT GOES
ALL THE WAY TO THE COLORADO
RIVER, TAKES IN ALL, OF ALL OF
IMPERIAL COUNTY. AND YOU LOOK AT
THE CHANGES IN, YOU KNOW, THE
CLIMATE CHANGE REALITY IS
EXACERBATING HARSH CONDITIONS
THAT AFFECT EVERYTHING FROM
MOBILITY TO HOUSING,
SUSTAINABILITY, ENERGY
CONSUMPTION, ALL OF THAT, WHICH
THEN, YOU KNOW, IS REALLY TOUGH
ON FOLKS WHO ARE BARELY BEING
ABLE TO HAVE THE ECONOMIC POWER
TO MEET THE TO MEET THE NEED,
AND, AND ARE THEMSELVES A VICTIM
OF THAT. SO I SEE IT AND I
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU EVERY
DAY. AND AND SOME OF THE
PRAGMATIC RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
YOU MAKE AROUND THE PUBLIC
POLICY SPACE AND, BUT WITH AN
EYE TOWARDS THOSE PARTICULAR
COMMUNITIES. THE OTHER THING I
SHOULD JUST TELL YOU TO THAT AND
COMMENT ON IS THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT MY AMAZING STAFF AND
I WORK ON ALL THE TIME, THAT'S A
FOCUS IS ON WORKING POVERTY IN
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AND THE
FACT THAT A GREATER AND GREATER
PERCENTAGE OF OUR LOW WAGE,
MINIMUM WAGE EARNERS ENTRY LEVEL
WORKERS IN THE WORKFORCE, ARE
NOW MORE DEPENDENT ON THOSE
TYPES OF JOBS FOR FULL TIME
SECURITY THAN FOLKS AT THAT SAME
PORTION OF THE WORKFORCE WERE
MANY DECADES AGO. THEY'RE SORT
OF STUCK IN THAT. AND THE DEMAND
ON THEIR LABOR HASN'T GONE
ANYWHERE. IN FACT, IT'S
INCREASED. AND YET THEY FIND
THEMSELVES STUCK IN WITHOUT
ECONOMIC MOBILITY, SORT OF IN A
COMPONENT OF THE WORKFORCE THAT
HAS HIGH DEMAND FOR THEIR LABOR,
WHERE THEY'RE HAVING TO WORK
MORE HOURS TO MAINTAIN
EQUILIBRIUM STATUS QUO JUST TO
MAKE BASIC NEEDS, AND WITHOUT
THE MOBILITY THAT THEIR
GRANDPARENTS HAD WHEN THEY SPENT
TIME IN THAT SEGMENT OF THE
WORKFORCE. SO THEY'RE STUCK AND
THAT I HAVE TERMED THEM THE
INVISIBLE WORKFORCE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THEY ARE BECAUSE
WE CONSUME THEIR SERVICES ALL
THE TIME, BUT WE DON'T.
EVERYBODY GETS REALLY
UNCOMFORTABLE WHEN I START
TALKING ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THESE FOLKS ARE STUCK AND MANY
OTHERS AND OF COURSE, THAT HAS A
DEEP IMPACT ON WOMEN, MOTHERS
AND THEY ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
REPRESENTED IN THAT COHORT,
WHICH MAKES IT HARD TO HAVE
PEOPLE ACCESS OPPORTUNITIES,
WHETHER IT'S EDUCATIONAL,
VOCATIONAL, WHETHER IT'S SUPPORT
PROGRAMS, WHETHER THEY'RE FREE
UP THAT TIME TO BUILD A LIFE. IF
YOU'RE JUST SPENDING YOU KNOW,
80 HOURS OF YOUR TIME JUST DOING
THAT. SO IT'S VERY MUCH A
CONCERN AND A FOCAL POINT. AND I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT TO SPEAK
TO THAT AT ALL ABOUT THAT
DYNAMIC IN THE WORKFORCE ITSELF.
BUT, SO, YOU KNOW, I CAN TELL
YOU AS ONE REPRESENTATIVE THAT
REPRESENTS THIS PART OF THE
STATE, YOU HAVE A LOT OF THOSE
THINGS ALL CONVERGING ON
POPULATIONS AND DEMOGRAPHICS AND
GEOGRAPHIC LOCATIONS, ALL AT THE
SAME PLACE AT THE SAME TIME. AND
IT'S VERY FRUSTRATING. AND SO
YOUR YOUR THOUGHTS AND INPUT ON
DRAWING THOSE LINKAGES, RIGHT,
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT AND
VALUABLE. SO I MEAN, WHAT I CAN
TELL YOU ABOUT IS THAT WHAT WHAT
WHAT KIND OF, RESEARCH WE HAVE
DONE IS ABOUT THE, THE, THE BIG
BURDENS THAT ARE PUT ON WOMEN
THAT THEY'RE, IT'S REALLY IRONIC
HOW THEY'RE SO IMPORTANT TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY, BUT IN A
WAY, IT SEEMS LIKE THEIR WAGES
HAVE ARE NOT ABLE TO GO UP. SO I
THINK IT'S PART OF THE
CONVERSATION THAT, WE WERE
SAYING BEFORE THAT WE NEED TO
TAKE TO TAKE THIS IDEOLOGY THAT
THE IMMIGRANT WORKER AND THE
LATINOS, THE LATINOS WORKERS,
IT'S SO BADLY FAR TOO VALUABLE
TO CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY. AND I
THINK THAT BY VALUING THEIR
THEIR KIND OF WORK, THAT'S WHERE
WE CAN START INTO FIRST
NARROWING THE GENDER PAY GAPS
AND ALSO UNDERSTANDING THAT,
THERE ARE SO MANY OTHER
CHALLENGES THAT IS NOT ONLY
ABOUT THE ECONOMY, IT'S ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE. IT'S ABOUT THE,
THE, THE GENDER INEQUITIES THAT
ARE WITHIN THE COMMUNITIES. I
THINK, AN INTERSECTIONAL
PERSPECTIVE IN TACKLING THIS
KIND OF ISSUES, NOT ONLY CLIMATE
CHANGE, BUT ANY OTHER POVERTY.
IF ONCE WE REALIZE THAT THERE'S
NOT JUST ONE SOLUTION, THERE ARE
MANY SOLUTIONS THAT NEED TO BE
IMPLEMENTED WITH AN
INTERSECTIONAL PERSPECTIVE, THEN
WE ARE ABLE TO DO SOME SOME KIND
OF CHANGE. APPRECIATE YOU VERY
MUCH. KEEP AN EYE ON MY EFFORTS
IN THE FUTURE. TO CONTINUE TO
PURSUE A HOUSING WAGE STANDARD
AND PROVIDE INCENTIVES FOR
EMPLOYERS TO ADOPT THOSE WAGES,
ALL OF WHICH HAVE RUN INTO
RESISTANCE IN THE LEGISLATURE.
BUT WE'RE NOT GIVING UP. SO I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF WAYS TO
GET AT THIS, AND I, I APPRECIATE
YOUR PRESENCE AND YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY. THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
AND NOW WE GET TO INTRODUCE
HELEN TORRES, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF HISPANAS ORGANIZED FOR
POLITICAL EQUALITY, AS A CEO OF
HOPE FOR 23 YEARS, HELEN TORRES
HAS STRATEGICALLY BUILT A LATINO
LEADERSHIP AND ADVOCACY
INFRASTRUCTURE IN CALIFORNIA,
COMPOSED OF THOUSANDS OF
CIVICALLY ENGAGED LATINO LEADERS
SERVING IN ELECTED AND APPOINTED
OFFICE AS BUSINESS,
PHILANTHROPIC, AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS. SHE HAS CREATED ROBUST
PATHWAYS TO LEADERSHIP FOR
LATINAS IN HIGH SCHOOL TO
LATINAS ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES, RESULTING IN OVER 1600
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS BEING
FILLED BY LATINAS. HELEN WAS
RAISED BY A SINGLE MOTHER
OUTSIDE OF DETROIT, MICHIGAN.
SHE'S A FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
GRADUATE. HER PASSION TO FIGHT
FOR WOMEN'S RIGHTS STEMS FROM
WITNESSING THE SEXUAL AND RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION HER MOTHER FACED
DAILY. WE WELCOME YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK AND FOR BEING
HERE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
PADILLA, AND FOR THIS
COMMISSION'S WORK AND FOR YOUR
OUTSTANDING LEADERSHIP. AS
MENTIONED, MY NAME IS HELEN
TORRES. I HAVE THE GREAT
PLEASURE OF BEING THE CEO OF
HOPE HISPANAS ORGANIZED FOR
POLITICAL EQUALITY, A NONPROFIT,
NONPARTISAN ORGANIZATION
COMMITTED TO ENSURING POLITICAL
AND ECONOMIC PARITY FOR LATINAS
THROUGH LEADERSHIP, ADVOCACY AND
EDUCATION TO BENEFIT ALL
COMMUNITIES AND THE STATUS OF
WOMEN. WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTRIBUTE TO
THIS MEANINGFUL DISCUSSION ON
FOSTERING BILATERAL
RELATIONSHIPS WITH MEXICO AND
CALIFORNIA THAT INTEGRATES A
GENDER PERSPECTIVE. LATINAS MAKE
UP 20% OF CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION AND REPRESENT A
GROWING DEMOGRAPHIC. I ALSO WANT
TO PUT A FINE POINT TO THAT,
THAT 25% OF LATINAS IN THE
UNITED STATES RESIDE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE DRIVING
PROGRESS. WE'RE DRIVING PROGRESS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES, CONTRIBUTING
TO THE ECONOMIC GROWTH AND
PARTICIPATING INCREASINGLY IN
THE POLITICAL PROCESS,
INTEGRATING A GENDER PERSPECTIVE
INTO DISCUSSIONS BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA AND MEXICO IS
ESSENTIAL FOR FOSTERING
INCLUSIVE AND EQUITABLE POLICIES
THAT TRANSLATE INTO POSITIVE
CHANGE FOR LATINAS, BY
EXTENSION, THEIR HOMES AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES. IT IS ALSO CRITICAL
THAT WE CREATE OPPORTUNITIES TO
ENSURE LATINA LEADERSHIP IS
REPRESENTED IN ALL LEVELS OF OUR
GOVERNMENT AND OUR CIVIC SOCIETY.
I SPECIFICALLY WANTED TO
SPEARHEAD A CONVERSATION AROUND
ONE OF HOPE'S LEADERSHIP
PROGRAMS. HOPE HAS A VARIETY OF
SERIES OF LEADERSHIP PROGRAMS
THAT BUILD COMMUNITY LATINA
COMMUNITY POWER BY PREPARING AND
SUPPORTING LATINAS AS CIVIC
LEADERS AND CREATING MEANINGFUL
SPACES TO FOSTER SOCIAL AND
CIVIC EXCHANGES. RECOGNIZING
THAT LATINA LEADERSHIP IS NOT
RESTRICTED TO THE US BORDER, WE
LAUNCHED A HOPE BINATIONAL
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM IN 2018,
WHICH IS A PROGRAM FOR
OUTSTANDING LATINA EXECUTIVES
FROM THE UNITED STATES AND Ã
MEXICO TO SUPPORT THEIR
LEADERSHIP INTO NATIONAL AND
GLOBAL STAGE. THE ASPIRATIONAL
GOAL OF THE FELLOWSHIP IS TO
PREPARE LATINA LEADERS ACROSS
THE WESTERN HEMISPHERE. WE OPT
TO BEGIN THE EXCHANGE WITH ONE
OF THE COUNTRIES WITH THE UNITED
STATES LARGEST TRADING PARTNER.
OF COURSE, MEXICO, AS BINATIONAL
FELLOWS. LATINAS CONNECT IN
PERSON AND VIRTUALLY TO UNEARTH
SHARED EXPERIENCES, CHALLENGES
AND SOLUTIONS FOR ADDRESSING THE
ISSUES OUR COMMUNITIES FACE,
BOTH LOCALLY AND GLOBALLY. THEY
ALSO SECURE SUPPORT FROM OTHER
LEADERS AS THEY PREPARE TO RUN
FOR OFFICE OR REACH NEW
POSITIONS OF LEADERSHIP IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AS THEY SHARE
STRATEGIES FOR MAKING CHANGES
ACROSS THE BORDER. THE
BINATIONAL FELLOWSHIP FOCUSES ON
ATTENTION OF ISSUES OF
IMPORTANCE FOR OUR BILATERAL
RELATIONSHIP, SPECIFICALLY TRADE
AGREEMENTS, DISPELLING HOW THEY
ARE CREATED TO BE MUTUALLY
BENEFICIAL, HOW THEY IMPACT BOTH
THE ECONOMY HERE IN MEXICO AND
THE UNITED STATES. WE TALK ABOUT
NATIONAL SECURITY AND ITS
INCREASING IMPORTANCE IN
RELATIONSHIP WITH MEXICO.
MEXICO, PARTICULARLY AS IT
RELATES TO TRAFFICKING, ILLICIT
DRUGS, GUNS AND HUMANS. THE
CONDITION OF THE BORDER HAS
OFTEN BEEN A TOPIC OF DISCUSSION
AMONGST ALL OUR WOMEN. WE ALSO
FOCUS ON ATTENTION ON THE STATE
OF DEMOCRACY AND THE GOVERNANCE
IN BOTH COUNTRIES. OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS, LOOKING AT THE ROLE
OF CIVIC SOCIETY IN PROTECTING
THE DEMOCRATIC INSTITUTIONS AND
PROMOTING DEMOCRATIC PRINCIPLES.
FINALLY, WE ALSO SPEND SOME TIME
LOOKING AT THESE ISSUES FROM A
WOMAN'S LENS AND DISSECTING THE
ROLE OF WOMEN IN MEXICO. AND
HERE IN THE AMERICAN SOCIETY,
HOW THEY ARE FARING IN
LEADERSHIP BOTH IN PRIVATE AND
PUBLIC SECTORS. I AM VERY PROUD
TO SAY THAT WE HAVE AN
INCREDIBLE LEADERSHIP PROGRAM
BECAUSE IT'S CHAIRED BY OUR
FORMER U.S. TREASURER, ROSARIO
MARIN, AND CURRENT JOURNALIST
AND THOUGHT LEADER FROM MEXICO,
VERONICA ORTIZ ORTEGA. WE ALSO
HAVE SOME NOTABLE GRADUATES FROM
THE PROGRAM, PERHAPS SOME, YOU
KNOW, SAN DIEGO SUPERVISOR NORA
VARGAS, WHO RECENTLY HELPED
ESTABLISH A CHIEF BINATIONAL
AFFAIRS OFFICE FOR SAN DIEGO
COUNTY, CALIFORNIA STATE LIMÓN
SENATOR MONIQUE LIMON, WHO HAS
BEEN LEADING AN EQUITY AND
TRANSPARENCY ISSUES FOR THE
STATE. WE ALSO HAD GOVERNMENT
MEXICAN GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
LIKE VANESSA RUBIO MARQUEZ, WHO
IS WHO'S PREVIOUSLY MEXICAN
UNDERSECRETARY OF FINANCE AND
PUBLIC CREDIT, AND MARIA CARMEN
ALANIS, FORMER CHIEF JUSTICE OF
THE MEXICAN ELECTORAL COURT.
THESE WOMEN AND THIS PROGRAM
BRING TOGETHER THE ABILITY AND
OPPORTUNITY TO NOT ONLY ELEVATE
WOMEN AND LATINO REPRESENTATION,
BUT TO HELP MOLD SOCIETY AND
CREATE CHANGE IN A SYSTEMATIC
WAY THAT IMPROVES THE QUALITY OF
LIFE OF COMMUNITIES ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE BORDER. AS WE ALL
NOTED, THIS IS A HISTORICAL YEAR
FOR MEXICO AS IT IS ELECTED ITS
FIRST FEMALE PRESIDENT. A
TESTAMENT TO THE PROGRESS BEING
MADE TOWARDS GENDER EQUALITY AND
REPRESENTATION. WHILE WE
CELEBRATE THIS REPRESENTATION,
THIS ACHIEVEMENT, WE ALSO NEED
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT ELEVATING
AND ELECTING LATINAS AND
MEXICANAS INTO LEADERSHIP ROLES
SHOULD NOT BE A ONE OFF
EXCEPTION, BUT IT SHOULD BE THE
NORM. THE FIRST WOMAN IN ANY
POSITION SHOULD NEVER BE THE
LAST. REPRESENTATION MATTERS AND
IT IS CRUCIAL THAT WE CONTINUE
TO BREAK BARRIERS AND CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CONTINUOUS
PLACEMENT OF LATINAS AND
DECISION MAKING ROLES. ONE OF
THE KEY THEMES AROUND POLICY
THAT WE WOULD LOVE TO SEE
ADDRESSED MORE FREQUENTLY IS
ADDRESSING POLITICAL VIOLENCE
AGAINST WOMEN. THIS INCLUDES
ADDRESSING ISSUES THAT THREATEN
THIS LEADERSHIP PIPELINE, SUCH
AS GENDER BIAS, LACK OF ACCESS
TO RESOURCES, AND CULTURAL
BARRIERS. WE MUST ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE REAL THREATS OF
VIOLENCE THAT WOMEN OF COLOR
FACE HERE IN THE UNITED STATES
AND IN MEXICO WHEN THEY DECIDE
TO RUN FOR OFFICE. THE CURRENT
POLITICAL CLIMATE ACROSS THE
NATION HERE IN THE UNITED STATES
IS FRAUGHT WITH ESCALATION,
ESCALATING RHETORIC AND
INCIDENTS OF VIOLENCE POSING
SIGNIFICANT RISKS TO INDIVIDUALS
IN ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT.
FEMALE ELECTED OFFICIALS, IN
PARTICULAR, FACE
DISPROPORTIONATE LEVELS OF
HARASSMENT AND INTIMIDATION, AS
EVIDENCED BY THE ALARMING
STATISTIC OUTLINED IN THE 2023
REPORT BY WOMEN CALIFORNIA
WOMEN'S LIST. THE REPORT FOUND
65% OF WOMEN SURVEYED
EXPERIENCED HARASSMENT DURING
THEIR CAMPAIGNS, COMPARED TO 50%
OF MEN IN A DEEPLY TROUBLING AND
THAT NEARLY IT IS DEEPLY
TROUBLING THAT NEARLY TWO THIRDS
OF WOMEN CANDIDATES HAVE
EXPERIENCED HARASSMENT DURING
THEIR CAMPAIGNS, WITH EVEN
HIGHER RATES AMONG WOMEN OF
COLOR AND LGBTQ, PLUS WOMEN.
THESE THREATS NOT ONLY UNDERMINE
OUR DEMOCRATIC PRINCIPLES, BUT
ALSO DETER QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS
FROM SEEKING PUBLIC OFFICE, THUS
WEAKENING THE DIVERSITY AND
REPRESENTATION WITHIN OUR
GOVERNMENT. EVERY CANDIDATE
DESERVES TO BE TO PURSUE THESE
POSITIONS WITHOUT FEAR OF
VIOLENCE OR RETALIATION,
CREATING SAFE AND SUPPORTIVE
ENVIRONMENTS. I WILL ALSO LIKE
TO CITE THAT IN MEXICO, A SURVEY
CONDUCTED BY THE MEXICAN
GOVERNMENT FOUND THAT 70% OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS OVER THE AGE OF
15 HAVE EXPERIENCED SOME KIND OF
VIOLENCE ENHANCING BILATERAL
RELATIONSHIPS ARE IMPORTANT.
HAVING THESE CONVERSATIONS THAT
ARE SOMETIMES VERY HARMFUL TO
OUR DIFFICULT TO HAVE AROUND
VIOLENCE, ESPECIALLY AGAINST
WOMEN, IS ALSO IMPORTANT.
KEEPING TRACK ABOUT OUR
DIVERSITY HERE IN CALIFORNIA, WE
COULD DO A BETTER JOB.
SPECIFICALLY, HOPE WOULD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT SB 782, CALIFORNIA'S
RICH DIVERSITY INCLUDES A
SIGNIFICANT LATINA POPULATION
AND ITS LEADERS IN PROMOTING
INCLUSIVE, EQUITABLE GOVERNANCE.
SB 72 782 BY SENATOR LIMÓN, A
BINATIONAL FELLOW ALUM, AS
MENTIONED, ENSURES THAT WE THAT
OUR EFFORTS TO ELEVATE DIVERSE
VOICES CONTINUE BEYOND
INDIVIDUAL RELATIONSHIPS OR
ADMINISTRATIONS. THIS IS AN
ADVOCACY TO ENSURE THAT OUR
GOVERNOR AND HOPEFULLY OTHERS IN
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS ARE VERY
TRANSPARENT ABOUT WHO THEY'RE
APPOINTING TO COMMISSIONS. IN
CONCLUSION, AS WE CELEBRATE THIS
HISTORIC YEAR, WE MUST COMMIT TO
DOING MORE TO SUPPORT AND
ELEVATE LATINAS INTO POSITIONS
OF POWER AND FOSTER PRODUCTIVE
DIALOG BETWEEN OUR LEADERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND MEXICO. WE HAVE
MUCH TO LEARN FROM EACH OTHER.
INVESTMENTS AND PROGRAMS LIKE
THE HOPE BINATIONAL FELLOWSHIP,
AS WELL AS WORK OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE, CREATE MEANINGFUL
SPACES FOR THIS BINATIONAL
DIALOG AMONG Kò LEADERS TO TAKE
PLACE AND ENSURE WE'RE
LEVERAGING OUR COLLECTIVE POWER
TO CREATE POSITIVE CHANGE FOR
LATINAS EVERYWHERE. WE THANK YOU
FOR ENSURING THAT GENDER IS THE
FOREFRONT OF THESE DISCUSSIONS,
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND FOR THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE AND FOR HELPING TO
CREATE NEW PATHWAYS AND
OPPORTUNITIES TO PROMOTE YOUNG
LATINAS AND POSITIONS OF
LEADERSHIP. SENATOR LIMÓN IS A
FRIEND AND A COLLEAGUE. AND ON
782, I'VE BEEN AN EARLY
SUPPORTER AND ASKED TO BE A
COAUTHOR. I WILL CONTINUE TO DO
THAT, BUT I SHARE THAT DESIRE TO
HAVE THAT KIND OF TRANSPARENCY
SO THAT WE CAN BUILD ON THOSE,
THOSE LESSONS AND ACTUALLY
PRODUCE MATERIAL RESULTS INSTEAD
OF JUST SPEAKING ABOUT IT
PHILOSOPHICALLY. SO WE STILL
HAVE, I THINK, EVERY ONE OF OUR
DISTINGUISHED GUESTS WHO
TESTIFIED HAVE REITERATED THAT
WE STILL HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO
DO, AND THAT IS OBVIOUS. BUT I
ALSO WHOLEHEARTEDLY ENDORSE AND
AGREE THAT THE UNCOMFORTABLE
CONVERSATIONS NEED TO CONTINUE.
AND, AGAIN, THE CIRCUMSTANCES
DIDN'T ALLOW US TO HAVE SOME OF
MY AMAZING COLLEAGUES WITH US
TODAY, BUT THEY'LL BE WITH US
NEXT TIME AND MAYBE, PERHAPS
LATER THIS EVENING WITH THAT
SAID, I CAN'T FORGET THE FACT
THAT WE'RE GRATEFUL TO HAVE A
GOOD AUDIENCE HERE TODAY, GOOD
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION, I HOPE. I
KNOW A NUMBER OF MEMBER
COMMISSION MEMBERS ARE HERE, IN
ADDITION TO OUR DISTINGUISHED
GUESTS AND THE COUNCIL, I WANT
TO OFFER AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT THAT WOULD MEAN
THAT ANYONE WHO IS HERE WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK TO THIS
CONVERSATION, OR ADD YOUR VOICE
OR COMMENTS, AGAIN, DEPENDING ON
HOW MANY OF YOU COME UP. WE WANT
TO BE JUDICIOUS WITH OUR TIME,
BUT PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME
FORWARD OR QUEUE UP HERE AT THE
MIC. IF ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO ADD
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. THIS
IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO DO SO AND GET IT
ON THE RECORD OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE. AND THE ONLY THING I
WOULD REQUEST IS THAT YOU WOULD
JUST STATE YOUR NAME FOR THE
RECORD. HI. I GUESS I'LL SPEAK,
SEEING A LARGE CROWD, HI. GOOD
AFTERNOON, AUGUSTO GONZALEZ, I'M
A BINATIONAL CITIZEN, A DAUGHTER
OF IMMIGRANTS. MY PARENTS
IMMIGRATED FROM MEXICO, THEY
GREW UP ON THE BORDER, AND
THAT'S WHERE THEY MET, MY MOM
HAD AN ACCOUNTING DEGREE THAT
UNFORTUNATELY DIDN'T TRANSLATE
HERE TO CALIFORNIA. SHE ENDED UP
EARNING HER HIGH SCHOOL DEGREE,
LATER FINDING, OTHER CAREER
PATHS AS AN UNDOCUMENTED WOMAN.
WORKING AS A CASHIER, WAREHOUSE
EMPLOYEE, LATER BEING A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER AND
UNFORTUNATELY, DUE TO HER
IMMIGRATION STATUS, HAD TO PIVOT,
I'M REALLY EXCITED TO SEE THE
WORK THAT YOU AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES WILL WILL WORK ON,
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE STATISTICS
AND THE POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT WERE PROVIDED HERE TODAY, I
FEEL LIKE I'M ONE OF THE SMALL
PERCENT PERCENTAGES OF LATINAS
WHO ARE ABLE TO GROW IN THIS
SMALL BUSINESS ECONOMIC POLICY
SPACE, AND I DEFINITELY FEEL
LIKE THERE'S MORE ROOM ON THE
TABLE FOR MORE LATINAS TO BE
HERE, SO I JUST REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS THAT
WERE PROVIDED HERE TODAY. HOPE
ALSO HAS AN ECONOMIC STATUS OF
LATINAS REPORT THAT ALSO
PROVIDES OTHER POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE CAN
CONSIDER, SO MORE LATINAS ARE IN
THE WORKFORCE. HIGHLY RECOMMEND
YOU TO TAKE A PEEK AT THAT. AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR MAKING
SPACE. OF COURSE. THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE WOULD LIKE TO COME
UP AND SHARE COMMENTS OR
THOUGHTS? PLEASE FEEL WELCOME.
AND IF NOT, I WANT TO THANK ALL
OF YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR PRESENCE
AND PARTICIPATION AT THIS TIME.
WE WILL ADJOURN THE SELECT
COMMITTEE AND, MAYBE WE'LL SEE
SOME OF YOU LATER THIS
AFTERNOON. AND THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR ATTENDING.